je pense qu'on va pouvoir démarrer
puisque les intervenantes et les
intervenants nous ont rejoints et tout
d'abord je souhaite souhaiter la
bienvenue à ces intervenants
intervenantes au sénateur et sénatrice
qui nous ont rejoint et à l'association
également des droits de l'homme de la
Sorbonne qui est avec nous ce matin et
je souhaite la bienvenue aussi au
vice-présidents Laurent qui est qui est
parmi nous ce matin qui ne fait pas
partie de la délégation et au président
kaner qui nous fait aussi l'honneur et
le plaisir de nous rejoindre ce matin
merci à vous deux de vous intéresser aux
travaux de la délégation mes chers
collègues mesdames et messieurs à
l'occasion de la Journée internationale
pour l'élimination de la violence à
l'égard des femmes qui a lieu tous les
ans le 25 novembre nous avons souhaité
organiser pour cette journée symbolique
en matière de lutte contre les violences
et la lutte contre la pour la protection
des victimes une conférence sur les
femmes
important de conflits armés c'est pas
une première pour la délégation de
travailler sur ces sujets là je salue
nos collègues de la commission des
affaires étrangères aussi de la défense
et des forces armées du Sénat parmi nous
aujourd'hui car nous savons souhaité
ouvrir cette réunion aux membres de la
commission le président Cambon
d'ailleurs cette excusé notre délégation
a publié il a presque 10 ans un rapport
intitulé pour que le viol et les
violents sexuels cessent d'être des
armes de guerre la question d'actualité
que je posais hier en séance fait écho
aussi à cette thématique question posée
à la ministre des Affaires étrangères je
vous cache pas que j'étais un petit peu
déçu par la réponse c'est une aparté
comme nous l'écrivions alors nous avons
la certitude que la lutte contre les
viols et les violences sexuelles
commises lors des conflits armés n'est
pas séparable de la lutte contre toutes
les violences faites aux femmes et
qu'elle est une part essentielle en
temps de guerre comme en temps de paix
du combat pour l'égalité entre les les
hommes et les femmes malheureusement 10
ans après les violences sexuelles
violent grossesse forcées stérilisation
forcée mutilation esclavage sexuelle les
viols sont toujours des armes de guerre
ce fléau fait des victimes toujours plus
nombreuses et les sanctions contre les
coupables sont rares ou dimensionnés
l'exemple de l'Iran en est illustration
notre première table ronde permettra de
dresser un panorama de la situation
actuelle et de l'ampleur de ces
violences dans le monde si nous pouvons
nous féliciter d'une meilleure
reconnaissance de ces violences à
l'échelle internationale depuis quelques
années notamment à la suite de
l'attribution du prix Nobel de la Paix à
Denis mucloyer et d'un diamourad la
question de la prise en charge des
victimes de violences liées au conflit
reste d'une grande actualité ce sera le
thème de notre deuxième table ronde
enfin le sujet des femmes en temps de
conflit armés supposent de traiter non
seulement des femmes victimes de
violence mais aussi de celles engagées
dans la défense de leur pays au sein
d'unité opérationnelle de combat
notamment c'est pourquoi nous avons
souhaité consacrer la troisième séquence
de cette conférence à la thématique de
l'engagement des femmes dans les
conflits armés contemporains et aux
enjeux actuels de la féminisation des
armées merci mesdames d'être avec nous
cette conférence s'annonce donc très
intéressante et passionnante et je
remercie vivement tous les participants
qui nous ont rejoints et qui sont
tous présents sauf en visio alors je
souhaite quand même vous dire que comme
il y a de la visio avec l'Ukraine on
sera peut-être amené à modifier le
l'organisation de cette table ronde
puisque parfois la technique ne suit pas
forcément
donc cette conférence elle est filmée et
souvent je me dis on devrait le dire au
début parce que s'il y en a une qui peut
gaffer c'est bien moi dès le début donc
elle est filmée elle est diffusée en
direct sur le site du Sénat et les
réseaux du sociaux du Sénat donc elle
sera également disponible ensuite en
vidéo à la demande donc je vais
immédiatement passer la parole à Martin
filleul qui va introduire cette première
table ronde et d'autres collègues
sénateurs et sénatrices de la délégation
me rejoindront ensuite à vous chers
collègues merci madame la Présidente
chers amis chers collègues mesdames et
messieurs je me propose donc de traiter
de ce thème le viol et les violences
envers les femmes toujours des armes de
guerre les viols et les violences
sexuelles sont des moyens de guerre
depuis toujours mais ils sont utilisés
comme arme de guerre de manière massive
dans les conflits contemporains la prise
de conscience de ce fléau augmente aux
années 1990 quand l'opinion
internationale a découvert les horreurs
commises en ex Yougoslavie et a eu
connaissance des dimensions stratégiques
du viol utilisé de manière massive à des
fins de nettoyage ethnique pour faire
porter l'enfant de l'ennemi à des femmes
utilisées comme esclave sexuel au Rwanda
l'intégration des viols de masse dans
une stratégie d'extermination ethnique a
pris une dimension nouvelle avec la
contamination des victimes de viol par
le virus du sida
depuis l'adoption de la résolution 1820
le 19 juin 2008 par le Conseil de
sécurité des Nations unies le viol est
qualifié de crimes de guerre contre
l'humanité et crime constitutif du crime
de génocide en dépit de l'opposition de
plusieurs pays le viol relève en outre
désormais officiellement de la Cour
pénale internationale
l'objectif est avec l'utilisation du
viol comme arme de guerre de détruire
des communautés entières notamment en
infligeant aux hommes d'assister au viol
des femmes de leur famille au-delà de la
victime c'est l'ensemble de sa
communauté que le viol cherche à
atteindre
cette barbarie concerne tous les âges de
très jeunes enfants parfois des
nourrissons de quelques mois comme des
personnes âgées les hommes et les jeunes
garçons ne sont pas épargnés ce qui
confère une dimension singulière à cette
violence dans des sociétés où elle est
particulièrement tabou les technologies
numériques permettant aux bourreau de
filmer ces atrocités ont ajouté la
menace permanente pour les victimes que
ces vidéos se retrouvent en ligne et que
leur calvaire soit connu de tous
pardonnez-moi
l'une des causes de l'expansion du viol
de guerre et que les conflits actuels ne
sont plus limitées à des champs de
bataille circonscrits mais atteignent
les lieux de vie des populations civiles
qui deviennent ainsi la cible de ces
violences
l'impact de celle-ci n'est pas limité au
territoire en crise les femmes
accueillies en Europe dans le cadre d'un
parcours migratoire ont dans une
proportion importante subie des
violences tant dans leur pays d'origine
que dans des camps de réfugiés
les exemples récents de telles violences
ne manquent malheureusement pas l'ONU a
documenté et vérifié plus de 2500 cas de
violences sexuelles liées au conflit
commises au cours de l'année 2020 dans
18 pays
la grande majorité de ces violences
visées des femmes et des filles pour
96%. ces violences sont par ailleurs
notoirement sous-déclarés selon l'ONU
des milliers de viol ont été documentés
en République Dominicaine en République
démocratique pardonnez-moi du Congo au
Soudan en Guinée en Libye en Syrie en
République centrafricaine au Sri Lanka
au Nigéria ou encore en Irak ou des
femmes Yezidis ont été enlevées ils
livraient comme esclave sexuel aux
soldats de l'État islamique
plus récemment dans des régions
montagneuses éloignées du nord et du
centre du Tigré en Éthiopie les femmes
et les filles sont victimes de violences
sexuelles au niveau de cruauté
incompréhensible d'après l'ONU depuis le
début des hostilités dans cette région
en novembre 2020 depuis le début de
l'année de nombreux témoignages sont
venus des crèmes dénoncent également des
pratiques de viols en série qui
s'inscrivent visiblement dans une
stratégie militaire visant à
déshumaniser les victimes et à
terroriser la population comme le relate
deux rapports Remus à l'ONU en septembre
2022 afin de dresser un état des lieux
de la situation actuelle au niveau local
au niveau global ainsi que plus
spécifiquement en Ukraine je souhaite la
bienvenue aux participants de cette
première table ronde deux d'entre elles
sont dans cette salle à mes côtés et je
l'en remercie Anne castagnos scène
responsable des relations extérieures
d'amnésiens International France et
experte des enjeux droits des femmes
Céline Bardet
fondatrice et directrice de we are not
weapon of War et deux autres
participantes qui devraient qui aurait
dû intervenir par
vidéoconférence de petits lukrennes et
que nous tenons à remercier sincèrement
pour leur disponibilité il s'agit de
Maurice Maurine décidément Mercier
journaliste correspondante de France
Info et de Radio Télévision Suisse en
Ukraine elle est malheureusement
empêchée par les récents bombardements
qui ont privé le pays en particulier
Kiev de trois de G4 et de tous les
moyens techniques qui nous auraient
permis d'entrer en communication avec
elle ce qui fait que nous projeterons le
documentaire qui lui a valu d'ailleurs
le prix Bayeux des correspondants de
guerre pour un reportage à bout de chat
ensuite nous écouterons Catherina cher
qui est président de la strada ONG de
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes en Ukraine si vous en étiez
d'accord donc je pourrais immédiatement
donner la parole à ces intervenantes et
en particulier à Anne castagnossen
danmesti international
je vous remercie
beaucoup madame la sénatrice mesdames
les sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
mesdames et messieurs je remercie
beaucoup la délégation au droit des
femmes du Sénat de nous donner à nouveau
la parole nous étions déjà là en 2013
dans le rapport que madame la Présidente
tout à l'heure vous n'étiez pas là moi
voilà et je ne suis pas sûr que le bilan
soit forcément très positif depuis
néanmoins il y a des avancées
importantes comme vous l'avez signalé en
au niveau international et je pense
qu'on en reparlera un petit peu tout à
l'heure
je le sais et c'est ce qui nous réunit
hélas aujourd'hui les filles et les
fillettes sont les premières victimes
des situations de conflit qui se
multiplient dans le monde on l'a dit la
liste qui vient d'être cité n'est
malheureusement pas exhaustive mais déjà
suffisamment terrifiante j'aimerais
citer quand même quelques chiffres les
chiffres sont froids il faudrait pouvoir
mettre un nom et un visage derrière
ces millions dont nous allons parler
c'est ce que nous efforçons de faire
souvent au niveau d'un munition
international en documentant des cas
individuels mais j'aimerais vraiment en
citer deux qui sont les derniers
chiffres donnus femmes donc des Nations
Unies sur le l'ampleur de la catastrophe
et surtout sur la tendance dramatique à
la hausse notamment depuis 3 ou 4 ans
donc les derniers chiffres pardon d'une
femme de sur 2021 c'est 44 millions de
femmes et de filles déplacées de force
donc à l'intérieur de leur propre pays
en raison de conflits à la fin de
l'année 2021 soit plus que jamais
auparavant ça jamais été ces chiffres
qui viennent du Haut Commissariat des
Nations Unies pour les réfugiés n'ont
jamais été aussi élevés et on parle de
511 millions de femmes et de filles qui
vivent dans des pays fragiles et de
conflits donc potentiellement exposé à
des violences extrêmes dont nous allons
parler aujourd'hui je vous remercie
madame etatrice d'avoir parlé de
l'Éthiopie parce que c'est un conflit
très méconnu hors du champ médiatique et
le plus souvent politique on en parle un
tout petit peu depuis une quinzaine de
jours en raison de l'accord de paix qui
vient d'être signé le 2 novembre mais
c'est un trou B1 dans les médias
français et même au niveau politique on
est plusieurs rendez-vous à la suite de
deux rapports publiés par un Mysty l'un
conjointement un swatch et on s'est
rendu compte que les élus qu'on a
rencontrés sont très souvent très peu
informés de ce conflit ce qui ne veut
pas dire qu'ils sont insensibles quand
dans la fixe ce qui se passait ça
s'explique aussi par le fait qu'il y a
aucun accès au pays
quasiment aucun observent aucun
observateur international on a accès à
la région du tigre occidental ou de la
zone Amaran en Éthiopie et les coupures
Internet n'ont pas aidé à la
médiatisation de ce conflit donc c'est
un conflit très très méconnu donc je
vous remercie vraiment de de l'avoir
évoqué
amnistie parle dans ce dans ce conflit
avec de nettoyage ethnique documenté
là on parle vraiment de on parle de
violence sexuelle généralisée vous
l'avez cité viol de masse esclavage
sexuel mutilation exécution sommaire
judiciaire etc et qui dans la mesure où
sont des campagnes clairement organisées
concertées relèvent effectivement de
crimes contre l'humanité en application
de définition du droit international
notamment de la CPI que vous avez que
vous avez cité donc ce conflit est
particulièrement
symptomatique j'allais dire de ce qu'on
va essayer de dénoncer aujourd'hui et
contre lesquels on essaie de lutter
depuis maintenant plusieurs décennies
pour parler du effectivement de
éclairer un petit peu ce tableau qui est
très sombre vous avez parlé des avancées
effectivement en au niveau de la
communauté internationale et qui sont
salués par un Missy il y a notamment j'y
reviendrai l'agenda fin paix sécurité
qui a été introduit par la résolution 13
j'allais dire fameuse en tous les cas
pour tous ceux d'entre nous et celle
d'entre nous qui s'intéressent à la
question la résolution 13,25 de
d'octobre 2000 du Conseil de sécurité
qui a été suivi par neutre la dernière
datant de 2019 et qui constitue du coup
un agenda très très charpenté et assez
solide sur tout ce qu'on peut faire en
matière de lutte contre les violences
sexuelles et également pour
l'autonomisation des femmes et la
participation des femmes
à la gestion des conflits à la
résolution des conflits donc c'était
c'est la partie innovante de cet agenda
on y reviendra si je veux pas dépasser
mon temps mais je pense qu'on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler
donc cette résolution 13 25 a ouvert cet
agenda avant même avant même cette
résolution 13-25 vous en avez parlé
madame le Statut de Rome donc qui
instaure la Cour pénale internationale a
pour la première fois son article 7
qualifié les violences sexuelles de
crime contre l'humanité dès lors qu'ils
sont perpétés dans le cas d'une attaque
généralisée au systématique entre une
population civile et en application
d'une politique d'État ou de groupes
armés distinction importante donc ça
c'est un élément très important qui
donne on part du Statut de Rome donc on
parle pas de de résolution
juridiquement non contraignante mais on
parle d'une convention qui s'impose au
123 états partis maintenant
il y aurait beaucoup pas dire certains
d'entre vous je pense certains sénateurs
sénatrices que je vois le savent il y
aurait beaucoup à dire sur la
transposition en droit interne du Statut
de Rome et même si c'est pas le lieu
aujourd'hui d'en parler néanmoins
amnistie lutte depuis nombre années en
lien avec la corniation Française pour
la Cour pénale internationale pour que
la France lève les fameux trois verrous
qui empêchent de fait que le Statut de
Rome soit opérationnel totalement
opérationnelle en France et permet de
lutter contre l'impunité au nom de la
compétence universelle ou
extraterritoriale je voulais juste le
citer parce que c'est un élément de
plaidoyer très important pour Amnesty et
ses partenaires même si c'est pas
complètement tué d'aujourd'hui mais ça
l'est quand même puisque l'application
ça te demande y compris son article 7
passe aussi par son opérationnalité en
droit français ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui
le deuxième traité que je souhaiterais
citer qui est aussi
j'allais dire un peu révolutionnaire
c'est le traité sur le commerce des
armes qui est entré en vigueur en 2014
qui a été signé en 2013
et très soutenu par la France d'ailleurs
aussi et qui en son article 7
précise un élément très important bon le
TCA pour pour les ONG en particulier
à instaurer une un élément extrêmement
important une disposition extrêmement
importante qui veut que
lorsqu'il y a risque que les armes
transférées
assistance technique etc transférer un
pays puisse être utilisé pour de la
Commission de violation des droits
humains vers des populations civiles je
le fais très court c'est transferts
d'armes doivent être interdits donc il
doit y avoir un contrôle sur les
transferts d'armes au regard notamment
de cette règle d'or du risque d'exaction
sur les populations civiles
et elle est donc précision importante
dans ce cadre là et je vous lis la
l'article l'article 7 si je fais pas
d'erreur également voilà l'article 7 4
du TCA lors de son évaluation donc de
ces autorisations de transfert d'armes
l'état parti exportateur tient compte du
risque que les armes classiques puissent
servir à commettre des actes graves de
viol de violence fondée sur le sexe ou
des actes graves de violence contre les
femmes et les enfants ou à en faciliter
la commission là encore on parle de
convention internationale endroit
positif qui s'impose aux États
signataires et on parle là de
111 ratification 130 États signataires
mais 111 États qui ont ratifié le traité
sur le commerce des armes
donc cette évolution normative qui est
très importante et qui qui vient
principalement comme l'agenda fait un
pccurité d'ailleurs de des leçons tirées
des horreurs des années 70 des conflits
notamment en ExF Yougoslavie et en
Rwanda et ses répercussions dramatiques
en République démocratique du Congo
c'est également son complétés par des
des engagements politiques très forts
donc qui ne sont pas des engagements
juridiquement contraignants des
engagements politiques très forts dans
des enceintes où on ne l'aurait pas
forcément attendu notamment le G7 sous
présidence britannique le G7 en 2013 a
introduit la question de la violence des
femmes dans les conflits dans son agenda
avec voilà un chapitre prévention des
violences sexuelles dans les conflits et
qui souligne notamment aussi
l'importance de de soutenir l'action des
des défenseurs des femmes ou hommes
défenseurs des droits humains qui sont
particulièrement menacés de manière
générale mais particulièrement dans les
zones de conflit cet engagement a été
réaffirmé sous le président françaises
en 2019 en avril 2019 par la déclaration
de Dinard endossée ensuite par la
déclaration finale du sommet de Biarritz
en août 2019 tout ça pour vous dire que
au sein du G7 encore une fois c'est un
engagement qu'on politique quand même
très fort des membres du G7 sont pas
très nombreux mais néanmoins c'est
important il y a une volonté très très
affirmée de s'emparer de ces questions
là encore une fois c'était pas forcément
dans l'ADN de ce de ce G7 donc ça paraît
particulièrement important j'aimerais
aussi citer fin juin dans la déclaration
finale de ce qui était Pékin + 25 est
devenu Pékin + 26 en raison du covid qui
était en fait là le forum génération
égalité qui c'est donc
conclu enfin le sommet a eu lieu en à
Paris en 2020 sous co-présidence
française et mexicaine et sous la
pression des ONG il faut le dire parce
que c'était pas forcément
dans la dans le programme en fait des
des états au départ a été intégré à cet
exercice ce qu'on appelle un mécanisme
particulier en fait qui là encore relève
de l'application de l'agenda femme
pccurité qui s'appelle le Global Compact
désolé pour le franglais ou pour
l'anglais mais il y a pas de il y a
malheureusement pas de traduction
précise qui donc
est vise accélérer la mise en oeuvre de
l'agenda fin de paix sécurité dans ce
cadre là les questions des violences
sexuelles faites aux femmes étant
d'ailleurs partie intégrante du
programme de Pékin de de 1982 en 1995
bon on en est pas encore à l'application
précise ce Global Compact n'a quasiment
pas de contenu mais au moins on a on a
une inscription politique ce qui permet
de d'avoir un levier important pour
demander aux États d'avancer sur cette
question là maintenant très rapidement
si j'ai encore deux trois minutes sur
l'agenda finp sécurité je pense que la
plupart d'entre vous
le connais mais j'aimerais quand même y
revenir très très brièvement donc c'est
un élément important ça a été mentionné
dans les les
interventions introductrices parce que
c'est la première fois que un texte
internationaux même si c'est des
résolutions encore une fois
juridiquement non contraignantes mais
mais en lumière les l'impact
disproportionné et démesuré des
confirmés sur les femmes et les filles
c'est tout c'est tout l'objet de
l'agenda MP sécurité et leur
sous-représentation voir leur non
représentation dans certains cas dans
les processus de paix et les mécanismes
de résolution de conflit donc la 13 25
je vous l'ai dit pose la première pierre
de cet agenda qui depuis a été
charpentée par 9 autres qui maintenant
20 ans on a fait on a fêté enfin un
minimum on a essayé de fêter ces 20 ans
de la jeune DAF un peu sécurité en
octobre 2020
donc cet agenda vit aussi à reconnaître
sur un pied d'égalité avec les hommes la
participation des femmes à la prévention
et aux règlements des conflits et à la
consolidation de la paix donc ça c'est
vraiment la partie très innovante de cet
agenda on les femmes ne sont plus
seulement victimes mais elles sont
reconnues comme actrice à part entière
dans la prévention la lutte contre les
violences la lutte contre l'impunité et
la restauration de la paix donc ça c'est
un élément très important les femmes
sont aussi actrices de paix et de
sécurité l'agenda 13 25 s'articule
grosso modo autour de 5 piliers donc la
question de la participation des femmes
je viens d'en parler dans les
négociations des instances de paix la
représentation de la science nationale
et international relative à la paix et
la sécurité la question de la prévention
donc en encourageant la mise en place de
stratégies efficaces qui permettent de
prévenir toutes formes de violence à
l'égard des femmes et des filles
un volet protection qui promet la
protection des droits donc c'est
beaucoup une approche par les droits
ainsi que la prise en compte des besoins
spécifiques des femmes et des filles en
période de conflit et de post conflits y
compris l'accès aux soins et aux droits
sexuel et reproductif et enfin les
secours et la reconstruction donc
encourager l'incorporation des
perspectives de genre dans les efforts
d'assistance de réinsertion et de
reconstruction des femmes victimes et
bien sûr la mise en place cet agenda ça
c'est un élément qui nous porte qui nous
tient très à coeur amnistie passe bien
sûr par la lutte contre l'impunité et la
promotion de l'ensemble de cet agenda
cet agenda se décline au niveau national
par des plans national d'action donc un
tout petit mot sur les trois plans
nationaux d'action pour la France
le premier donc le premier a été adopté
son des plains trienos donc le premier a
été adopté en octobre 2010 le second a
été adopté pour la période 2015-2018
donc et le troisième avec trois ans de
retard ce contre quoi nous avons
beaucoup
nous sommes beaucoup combinés auprès du
Quai d'Orsay mais ça il y a eu juste
trois ans de d'interruption entre le
plan 2015-2018 et celui qui vient d'être
adopté en 2021 ce qui est pas un très
bon signe politique quand même de la
volonté française de l'application de ce
plan alors même que sur le second plan
le premier notamment le second avait été
très inclusif l'intérêt de ce plan aussi
dans sa préparation si à la fois même si
c'est le Quai d'Orsay qui est à la
manœuvre en termes d'intermistériel mais
c'est d'inclure tous les ministères et
les instances type office de protection
des refuses apatrides aussi
la cellule diplomatique de lisez à
propos de l'Ukraine avec notre ancienne
directrice de d'amnistie Ukraine
donc la conseillère Europe de d'Emmanuel
Macron et tout à fait le dialogue très
ouvert tout à fait sur notre ligne elle
en est pas là mais quels sont les moyens
comment comment la France peut-elle agir
donc voilà typiquement ce cadre du plan
national d'action qui engage la France
qui engage politique quand la France est
typiquement un cadre très utile dans ce
dans ce conflit la même chose pour
l'Éthiopie on dit à la France voilà
c'est l'occasion pour la France de
demander l'appliquer de mettre en oeuvre
son plan d'action nationale demander son
application de se mobiliser au niveau
des Nations Unies sachant que
politiquement c'est compliqué aux
Nations Unies l'Éthiopie nagea n'a
jamais été mis à l'agenda du fait du
veto russe et chinois en revanche le
Conseil droit de l'homme s'en est emparé
avec un mécanisme de de commission
d'expert sur l'enquête et la
documentation de ces cas donc c'est
c'est encore une fois c'est un outil
utile et qui ne suce que si l'on s'en
sert ce à quoi j'encourage tout le monde
voilà très brièvement donc je
juste pour pour conclure je lisais ces
plans d'action nationaux doivent être un
cadre à utiliser et à
donner du contenu le bilan de
l'application de la 13 25 je vous ai
cité les chiffres n'est pas forcément
très positif au regard de l'état du
monde mais il y a vraiment une question
de volonté politique et d'action à la
fois des ONG de la société civile et
bien sûr des parlementaires auxquels
nous nous adressons aussi aujourd'hui
pour interpeller le gouvernement
français et qui prennent toute sa part
en fait dans le dans ce l'application de
cet agenda et la lutte contre l'impunité
envers les auteurs de violence
gravissime faites aux femmes et aux
filles merci beaucoup
je vous remercie également madame de
votre intervention très précise qui pose
parfaitement le cadre juridique dans
lequel nous nous trouvons actuellement
et je me propose de vous donner la
parole madame Bardet vous qui
représentez donc l'ONG not
chaque fois autrement dit nous ne sommes
pas des armes de gala je vous remercie
infiniment pardon pour pour le nom
anglais
de cette ONG qui est bel et bien basée
en France cela dit et donc nous ne
sommes pas les armes de guerre d'abord
bonjour à toutes et à tous et merci
mille fois pour pour cette invitation je
vais essayer de tenir mes 10 minutes
voilà je regarde
je voulais commencer pour en
rebondissant sur sur votre
discours d'ouverture quand vous dites
que nous avons la certitude que la lutte
contre les viols et les violences
sexuelles commises lors des conflits
armés n'est pas séparables de la lutte
contre toutes les violences faites aux
femmes évidemment j'adhère à 1000% mais
j'avais envie de rajouter aussi que
cette lutte n'est pas séparable non plus
de la question de la bonne gouvernance
en fait de manière générale parce que
quand on parle de violences sexuelles
dans les conflits armés on parle de pays
en conflit et donc on parle de la
question de l'État droit et de la bonne
gouvernance donc il y a un rôle aussi à
jouer
peut-être pour nous en France en termes
de diplomatie sur ces questions là parce
que la France et c'est de faire un
souvent et donc je voulais souligner ça
ensuite
la question était un petit peu quel est
le
quel est le bilan aujourd'hui quel est
l'ampleur des violences sexuelles dans
les dans les conflits armés c'est très
difficile et hier j'intervenais aux ses
yeux et nous ça fait de nombreuses
années qu'on demande à être financé pour
faire une étude mondiale qui n'existe
pas
sur l'ampleur des violences sexuelles
dans les conflits armés alors il y a des
chiffres qui ont été donnés
effectivement s'agissant du nombre de
femmes déplacées et merci d'avoir noté
parce que c'est vrai que si en
augmentation du nombre de femmes et
jeunes filles qui se trouvent dans des
zones de crise ou dans des zones de
conflits maintenant la question la
difficulté qu'il y a c'est celle de
savoir quel est l'ampleur de ces
violences sexuelles dans ces conflits ou
dans ces zones de crise j'ai envie de
dire quel est le modus opérandit aussi
de ces violences sexuelles qui sont les
violeurs parce que on parle aussi
beaucoup des victimes qui sont les
violeurs comment tout ça est opéré et
pourquoi je parle de tout ça parce que
pour ceux qui me connaissent pas je suis
juriste et enquêtrice criminelle
internationale je travaille sur les
crimes de guerre et j'ai fondé we are
Noten of War en 2014 qui est une toute
petite structure qui n'a pas d'argent
une toute petite structure mais pourquoi
j'ai fondée parce que je travaille
énormément sur le terrain et que les
constats que j'ai fait aussi c'est que
même si aujourd'hui et il faut s'en
féliciter moi je le dis aussi à chaque
fois parce qu'il y a eu beaucoup de
progrès on parle des violences sexuelles
dans les conflits on en parle beaucoup
plus dans les médias
j'aime à penser j'en suis quand même un
peu convaincue aussi que malgré le nom
anglais mais le la création de
up war en France a amené aussi un
plaidoyant en France qui manquait un peu
sur ces questions souligne et je suis
déçue qu'on écoute pas Maureen Mercier
mais parce que le travail que fait
Maureen Mercier en tant que journaliste
qu'elle a fait en Ukraine mais ce
qu'elle a fait aussi avant sur la Libye
et notamment sur le viol des hommes je
vous invite tous à regarder son travail
parce que comme vous l'avez souligné
aussi ça concerne les hommes et les
petits garçons et les garçons pardon
elle fait un travail formidable donc
c'est important qu'on en parle et donc
je faisais je suis juriste parce que il
y a toute la question de
l'accompagnement dont j'ai compris qu'on
va parler dont on va parler dans la
seconde session et toute la question
aussi de la justice et comment en
justice d'une part assez victime donc
comment
on leur donne aussi la parole et quand
je dis justice il y a bien entendu le
processus judiciaire évidemment qui est
important mais il n'y a pas que ça en
fait la justice pour les victimes quand
vous leur parlez pour elle c'est d'abord
qu'on les croit qu'on reconnaisse leur
histoire qu'on qu'on
j'allais dire qu'on adopte c'est pas ça
mais qu'on valide leur histoire et ça
c'est extrêmement important parce que la
plupart du temps comme vous le savez
aussi s'agissant des violences sexuelles
endroits communs on a tendance à
remettre en cause souvent les
témoignages des personnes donc ça c'est
quelque chose qui est important pour
elle et la deuxième chose on parle
beaucoup aujourd'hui des réparations
donc quelle forme de réparation on peut
donner aux victimes c'est un sujet qui
est même actuellement en cours en
Ukraine alors que nous sommes en plein
conflit en Ukraine les réparations elles
peuvent prendre différentes formes mais
elles passent par le processus
judiciaire pour certaines mais pas que
et
s'agissant de cela il y a quelque chose
aussi d'extrêmement important c'est que
à comprendre c'est que la temporalité
des victimes ça n'est pas celle des
médias ça n'est pas celle des
institutions internationales c'est
souvent pas celle des pardons des
politiques
et ça n'est aussi souvent pas celle des
bailleurs de fonds c'est-à-dire que la
question des violences sexuelles dans
les conflits comme vous l'avez souligné
ça crée des traumas absolument
gigantesque
qui dure des années s'ils sont pas pris
en charge la justice elle est lente
aussi il y a tout un travail invisible à
faire s'agissant de la justice et c'est
le secteur
j'allais dire dont on parle le plus
quand on parle des crimes de guerre et
notamment des viols de guerre en
soulignant le fait qu'il y a une
impunité ce qui est vrai mais qui n'est
pas totalement vrai non plus et j'y
reviendrai mais c'est le sujet dont on
parle de plus et c'est celui qu'on a
encore le plus de mal à financer
pourquoi je dis parce qu'il y a les
appuis à la Cour pénale internationale
il y a les tribunaux pénaux
internationaux mais il y a tout ce
travail qui est souvent fait par la
société civile d'enquête d'analyses la
collaboration avec les unités d'enquête
judiciaire nous on travaille avec les
unités en France notamment vous avez
souligné la question de la compétence
universelle qui est extrêmement
importante
donc il y a un appui à faire sur ces
questions là
ensuite nous on a développé ensuite il y
a la question de comment on fait pour
identifier ces victimes qui restent
invisibles pour une immense majorité
c'est à dire que souvent pour des
victimes qu'on entend parler aujourd'hui
grâce d'ailleurs au travail des
journalistes et c'est vrai que le
travail de Maureen Mercier qui a eu
cette victime ukrainienne avec un
témoignage extrêmement fort d'un coup
créé un impact émotionnel public qui est
important mais pour une victime qui
parle ce sont des dizaines voire des
centaines qui ne parlent pas qui ont
accès à rien et la création de We Are
Noten of War en fait ça a été celle de
se dire
en voyant ce qui se passait sur le
terrain de comment on peut réfléchir à
révolutionner le système parce qu'ils ne
fonctionne pas et pourquoi ils
fonctionnent pas parce que la plupart
des dont dans le cas des victimes on va
demander aux victimes d'aller porter
plainte d'aller voir un médecin d'aller
auprès des services or elles ne peuvent
pas le faire soit parce que les
questions de sécurité sur des zones de
conflit je vous laisse imaginer sont pas
possible soit aussi parce que elles
peuvent pas elles sont pas en capacité
psychologique de le faire donc
moi je me suis dit il faut mettre en
place un système qui leur permettent de
se signaler de dire je suis là vous avez
évoqué la République démocratique du
Congo je travaille beaucoup avec le
docteur Denis mon courrier le kivou cet
immense
on fait des kilomètres des dizaines des
centaines de kilomètres pour arriver au
fond de nulle part pour trouver une
victime
j'espère qu'on pourra écouter juste une
Masika de Goma qui qui aussi fait un
travail absolument extraordinaire en
République démocratique du Congo et donc
tout ça pour dire que c'est victime il
faut qu'on mette en place un moyen pour
qu'elle puisse se signaler il faut qu'on
apporte les services là où elles sont
parce que la plupart d'entre elles elles
ont énormément de difficultés à accepter
surtout au départ de bouger de venir
d'aller suivre un appui psychologique
tout ce qu'on peut proposer qui en fait
ne correspondent pas à leurs besoins
c'est pour ça que je parlais de
temporalité parce que moi je rencontre
beaucoup de victimes qui quand elles ont
subi ces viols ne sont pas prêtes en
fait sont pas prêtes pour la justice
sont pas prêtes aussi y compris parfois
sur les appuis médicaux urgents bien sûr
qu'elles le font parce qu'elles n'ont
pas le choix mais le reste souvent elles
sont pas prêtes et en fait il faut pas
forcer ça et puis après on a ces
victimes qui plusieurs mois après
viennent et disent je veux aller en
justice je pense que j'ai besoin d'un
psychologique je pense je veux raconter
mon histoire parce que souvent aussi au
début elle n'arrive pas à raconter ce
qu'il aurait été arrivé et puis ensuite
elles veulent le faire donc il faut
créer des espaces qui leur permettent ça
et travailler en fait à leur rythme
plutôt que parfois au nôtres et donc
c'est valable aussi pour la justice et
c'est toute la difficulté
des témoignages et des éléments de
preuve dont on parle beaucoup et je
terminerai parce que je crois que j'ai
voilà j'arrive dans mes 10 minutes
donc nous nous avons créé un outil qui
s'appelle backup qu'on s'apprête à
lancer en Ukraine et qu'on va lancer
dans le monde entier qui est un système
d'alerte sécurisé à travers un lien qui
a la forme d'une implication mais qui
est un lien avec un questionnaire
judiciaire et qui permet aux victimes de
s'alerter de s'enregistrer de donner des
éléments de preuve etc et surtout d'une
part ça nous permet des identifier et
donc de faciliter l'assistance de
pouvoir les renvoyer ou avertir les
services sur place des besoins qu'il y a
et puis de l'autre côté on a un outil
d'analyse criminelle qui je perds toutes
ces informations qui les analysent qui
peuvent être utilisés pour des
poursuites judiciaires ou en appui
d'enquête encore une fois par exemple
les gendarmes en France ou les
enquêteurs la Cour Pénale international
nous contactent pour les informations
dont il pourrait avoir besoin mais c'est
aussi raconter leur histoire c'est aussi
mémoriser leur histoire et ces mémoriser
leur histoire à travers leurs voix à
elle et c'est vrai que ça a été beaucoup
dit aussi on a beaucoup regardé les
femmes et jeunes filles comme victimes
et elles le sont de violences absolument
terribles mais elles sont aussi actrices
et elle lutte aussi aujourd'hui beaucoup
et elles prennent beaucoup la place les
victimes elles-mêmes pour raconter leur
histoire à travers leur voix et ça c'est
extrêmement important et il faut qu'on
soutienne ça un maximum parce que elles
n'ont pas besoin d'intermédiaire en fait
il faut que elle puisse parler et elle
elles sont en mesure aussi d'exprimer
leurs besoins que ce soit en termes de
justice en terme de en termes d'appui
elle elles savent elles connaissent leur
culture elles savent ce qui est possible
de faire moi par exemple je travaille
beaucoup en Libye autant vous dire qu'en
Libye c'est très compliqué imaginez-vous
bien que une femme libyenne qui a été
violée elle ne peut même pas accepter
qu'un médecin vienne la voir donc nous
on a fonctionné avec des systèmes de
photos à travers backup qui permet de
voir les blessures qui permettent le
médecin et donc ça crée un vecteur un
premier contact
voilà la dernière chose c'est que nous
on va lancer un nouveau site internet
donc je le dis qui aura beaucoup
d'informations et notamment qui aura une
carte on a une carte qui est jouée à
devenir interactive si on arrive à gérer
la technique mais en tout cas on a une
carte que en fait je sais bête on aurait
pu l'approcher aujourd'hui mais on a une
carte qui donne une vision de l'ampleur
des violences sexuelles dans le monde
depuis la Seconde Guerre mondiale on
aurait pu même remonter avant mais et
c'est intéressant à voir parce que il
suffit de regarder cette carte et de se
rendre compte que c'est un problème qui
n'a pas de religion qui n'a pas de
culture qui n'a pas de frontière on
viole en Bosnie-Herzégovine dans les
Balkans j'ai travaillé au Tribunal pénal
international pour lex Yougoslavie
pendant des années 12 ans dans les
Balkans il y avait des camps de viol
vous l'avez aussi souligné cette arme
nettoyage ethnique des camps de viol
faire qu'on met des femmes dans un camp
et on les viole en leur disant on est en
train de purifier de te purifier donc
c'est un outil qui a des objectifs
voilà et je pense que j'ai à peu près
tout dit je crois merci beaucoup c'est
nous qui vous remercions Madame Bardet
pour votre témoignage et également pour
votre action donc comme je vous en
parlais tout à l'heure donc nous devions
entrer en communication avec Maureen
Mercier mais elle est empêchée et on le
comprend on le comprend bien par les
bombardements acquieschent et par donc
les moyens techniques qui nous
permettent pas d'entrer en communication
et donc nous allons je crois entendre
son reportage qui lui a valu donc le
prix à Bayeux du reportage de guerre
dans la catégorie radio
ceci étant j'ai avec une certaine
émotion j'ai quand même envie de vous
lire le mail que Maureen Mercier nous a
transmis
puisqu'elle disait qu'elle tenterait de
se mettre en contact avec nous mais que
les choses étaient improbables et elle
m'a demandé de vous lire le mail qu'elle
nous transmet qui est très émouvant je
dirais donc elle dit il me tient à cœur
d'ajouter que si les femmes ukrainiennes
ont été et sont victimes de viol les
horreurs dont j'ai été le témoin 6 ans
durant en Afrique du Nord sont
infiniment plus alertantes encore là-bas
il est plus difficile de trouver une
femme migrante qui n'aurait pas été
violée que l'inverse le viol est
systématique les femmes sont vendues
pour la prostitution forcée torturée et
tabassés les milices ne les laissent
sortir que lorsqu'elles ont été trop
violées
usé souvent enceinte de plusieurs mois
ils sont débarrassent lorsque de
nouvelles migrantes arrivent de la chair
fraîche souvent elles tombent enceinte
de leur violeurs elles sont parfois
violées de durant leur parcours qui les
mènent en Libye et sur place c'est
systématique j'ai passé 6 ans à
recueillir ces témoignages édifiants des
tortures sexuellement tellement
effroyables que je ne peux les écrire
ici l'empathie est nécessaire pour les
Ukrainiennes et évidentes mais
l'empathie est surtout l'action pour
stopper la violence sur les femmes
migrantes en Libye est une nécessité
absolue
d'autant que nous Européens portons une
responsabilité sur leur sort via le
financement des garde-côte libyens qui
ramènent ces femmes sur le sol libyen
pays en guerre
je tenais absolument à vous faire part
de cette témoignages parce qu'il est il
dépasse tout ce qu'on peut imaginer je
peux me permettre juste vraiment ça ne
m'étonne pas de Maureen quel effet
témoignage et je pense que c'est
extrêmement important et j'ajoute que
s'agissant des migrants et aussi par
ailleurs l'Ukraine qui a généré beaucoup
de réfugiés etc il y a un autre problème
c'est que tout ces témoignages là qui
peuvent servir d'éléments de preuve
pardon mais c'est la juriste qui part
mais ils sont pas pris en fait parce que
il y a un travail d'enquête sur les
territoires en conflit ou en crise mais
les personnes qui se déplacent en fait
on n'a pas de système pour prendre leur
témoignages et les Ukrainiens ils
s'aèrent aussi de ça à juste titre parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de personnes qui ont
fui l'Ukraine et qui sont qui ont été
elles-mêmes victimes de choses et qui
peuvent pas donc backup c'est aussi
l'idée de pouvoir tracer ça mais la
question des femmes migrantes et des
hommes il s'avère que moi je suis juge à
ses soeur à la Cour nationale de aussi
dans mes multiples fonctions on l'entend
énormément donc je suis je suis ravie
qu'elle allait parler de ça parce que
c'est vrai que c'est un sujet énorme les
violences sexuelles sur la route des
migrations et sur l'exil
donc je pense qu'on va pouvoir lancer le
film ça fonctionne
mon micro ne marche pas c'est ça si il
marche c'est parti
vous n'avez pas besoin de témoignages
très rares que vous allez entendre
maintenant et ils sont difficiles ils
décrivent l'horreur que des femmes des
filles ont vécu à bout de chat en
Ukraine une mère a accepté de briser le
silence de raconter ce qu'elle a enduré
des viols continuent les soldats avaient
quasiment élu domicile chez elle sont
chez elle qu'ils ont transformé en enfer
Maurine merci vous êtes notre envoyé
spécial RTS en Ukraine cette femme et sa
fille vous ont accordé leur confiance
nous allons entendre des extraits des
trois heures d'entretien que vous avez
enregistré avec elle leur voit ont été
modifiées nous l'appellerons et Katarina
elle a 38 ans elle vit dans une petite
maison à bout de chat avec sa fille 13
ans sa mère 75 ans sa mère trop âgée
pour fuir voilà pourquoi ces trois
femmes ont dû faire face subir
l'occupation russe elle m'a dit je vous
raconte tout une fois pour toutes il
faut que les femmes sous occupations
russes sachent qui ils sont et de quoi
ils sont capables il faut que le monde
sache cette femme dit ce n'est pas à moi
d'avoir honte voilà comment comment son
histoire
[Musique]
la première fois qu'ils sont venus il
faisait jour ma voisine m'a fait un
signe pour que je comprenne que je
n'avais pas d'autre choix que de les
laisser entrer et j'étais terrorisé il
pointait leurs armes sur moi et tirait
en l'air je les ai laissés entrer
la nuit ils sont revenus ils m'ont
demandé de m'a genouiller puis ils m'ont
dit ta fille est très belle je te les ai
supplié de ne pas la toucher je leur ai
dit fait tout ce que vous voulez avec
moi mais ne la touchez pas ils m'ont
forcé à leur faire des fellations à tour
de rôle ça n'en finissait pas y défilait
comme un tapis roulant
pour protéger sa fille cette femme va se
faire violer ainsi plusieurs fois par
jour durant deux semaines et demi les
soldats ne venaient jamais seuls
toujours en groupe
[Musique]
dire sinon il tirait en l'air entre nos
jambes
je leur rappelais qu'ils avaient une
famille des enfants mais ça ne les
calmez pas
tous les jours il venait me violer tous
les jours même lorsque j'avais mes
règles il s'y mettait à plusieurs
je crois que seuls mes yeux et mes
oreilles n'ont pas été violées
[Musique]
on était en poste en Biélorussie et ça
fait longtemps qu'on n'a pas eu de
femmes alors ferme-la
de détruire le quartier
de tuer tout le monde
mes voisins ma fille
donc cette femme c'est sacrifié durant
ces deux semaines et demi elle a tout
fait pour survivre et surtout sauver sa
fille ainsi que ses voisins en tentant
en vain de calmer ce qu'elle définit
d'un mot psychopathe
beaucoup de mes voisins et qu'il pouvait
nous tuer à n'importe quel moment enfant
grand-mère ou un animal pour eux c'était
du pareil au même il ne cessait de me
demander où est-ce qu'il y a des jeunes
je leur répondais que je ne savais pas
je leur disais que tout le monde avait
fui la ville oui ils m'ont dit tu es et
qu'il violait des enfants
à ses côtés sa fille 13 ans
se faire violer pour que j'apprenne
disait-il pour qu'il puisse nous
utiliser tous les deux une huile sont
venues à 8 je dormais et sont venus dans
le lit m'ont touché mais finalement ils
sont allés vers ma mère ils l'ont violé
les 8 en même temps
[Musique]
il me disait tu penses vraiment qu'on ne
va pas violer ta fille alors qu'on viole
d'autres enfants fille et garçon et moi
je tentais de les implorer en leur
disant oui j'ai peur mais on peut être
amis nous faisions partie d'un seul pays
l'Union soviétique il disait que leur
vie était horrible là où ils habitent
alors je leur disait vous pourrez
revenir ici mais maintenant ne touchez à
personne cesser de tuer j'ai essayé de
leur parler ainsi parfois
et puis tout à coup le regard tournait
il redevenait fou d'un coup ils étaient
totalement imprévisibles j'ai vraiment
eu le sentiment qu'on n'avait pas devant
nous des soldats mais des gens échappés
de l'hôpital psychiatrique qu'on leur
avait donné des armes et envoyer faire
la guerre mais ils ne sont pas normaux
la mer décrit ses militaires
systématiquement
ivre et qui pillaient du haschich dans
les maisons qui tiraient sur le portail
pour signaler qu'ils arrivaient chez
elle et qui restaient des heures durant
dans sa cour à se balançait comme des
pendules après l'avoir violée sa fille
n'a pas échappé non plus à cette torture
psychologique
de mes voisins et le militaire m'a dit
regarde c'est ce que j'ai fait ce matin
c'est la femme que j'ai tué il y avait
du sang qui coulait de sa bouche j'ai
attendu qu'elle souffre avant de
l'achever
je lui dis vous avez vraiment fait ça il
m'a répondu oui j'aime tuer ça m'excite
il avait 18 ans 5 ans plus que moi
[Musique]
lunettes de vision nocturne on a compris
qu'il voyait exactement sur qui il
tirait qu'il savait ce qu'il faisait
quand il tuait des civils
il y a un soldat qui nous disait ce
n'est pas une guerre c'est du terrorisme
c'est de la torture psychologique comme
ça votre président Zelenski va finir par
comprendre qui on est
[Musique]
marine cette femme et sa fille décrivent
des militaires très jeunes oui entre 18
et 25 ans salaire mensuel selon ce que
ces soldats ont dit à ces femmes
l'équivalent pour la plupart de 250
francs par mois
de région de l'intérieur de la Russie de
yakouti notamment oui et bien d'autres
habitants du quartier me l'ont confirmé
et Catharina
il mettait des préservatifs il les avait
volés dans des magasins il piquaient
tout des gadgets tout il devenait de
yakouti et des régions encore plus loin
pour eux nos magasins c'était le paradis
les préservatifs je ne suis pas sûr
qu'ils en avaient vu avant et trouver
cela incroyable
Vladivostok encore plus loin où la vie
est terriblement dure je crois qu'ils
ont choisi volontairement ces jeunes ils
étaient épatés par tout même par nos
maisons
[Musique]
et cette mère conclue en disant je crois
mais je ne suis pas sûr que nous avons
survécu le courage de parler elle le
trouve dans sa colère contre les
autorités ukrainiennes contre le maire
de Bucha elle qui veut pourtant déposer
plainte et c'est extrêmement rare la
plupart des femmes ne réussissent pas à
dénoncer ce qu'elles ont enduré 11 jours
après la libération de sa ville
personne n'est venu me demander si
j'avais besoin d'aide le maire il a été
le premier à déguerpir lorsque les
Russes nous ont envahi et c'est le
premier qui est revenu jouer les héros
devant les caméras lorsque les rues sont
fuis je ne fais plus confiance à
personne désormais
auparavant je soutenais le président
plus maintenant encore moins le maire de
bout de chat ces derniers jours après le
départ des Russes il n'a même pas été
fichu de nous fournir des générateurs on
a tous besoin d'électricité
ces hommes du quartier qui m'ont laissé
parfois entendre qu'elle aurait pu
peut-être éviter ce qui lui est arrivé
voilà ce qu'elle réplique
ceux qui ont essayé de résister sont
morts où ils ont été obligés de voir
leurs enfants se faire violer sous leurs
yeux je ne sais même pas comment c'est
possible de voir cela j'ai regardé ces
hommes droits dans les yeux ils étaient
ivre mort et fous j'ai compris ce que je
devais faire
je n'ai pas honte de ce qui m'est arrivé
j'ai plus honte pour ceux qui ont fui en
abandonnant leurs parents âgés derrière
eux peut-être que j'ai tort mais je
crois qu'il est mieux de se faire violer
si c'est ce qu'il faut pour protéger
votre enfant et votre mère que de les
abandonner
elle a pu enfin passer une expertise
médicale hier 11 jours après la
libération de bouts de chat Laurine vous
avez plus documenter les blessures
encore visibles sur son corps vous avez
parlé aussi à une psychologue qui fait
partie d'une cellule d'urgence elle
commence à avoir une vue d'ensemble de
la situation et confirme qu'elle reçoit
toujours plus de cas et notamment des
cas de viol d'une violence inouïe de
mineur comme équatarina évoquait tout à
l'heure vous allez l'entendre la
psychologue évoque ici de cas parmi les
maintenant 12 femmes et mineurs qu'elle
a pris en charge deux cas dont elle a
tenu à nous faire part la première
victime que j'ai reçue à 13 ans sans
comme l'enviolet l'un après l'autre et
aujourd'hui elle est enceinte ces hommes
l'ont violaient début mars il l'ont
frappé pour l'empêcher de elle a encore
les marques des coups plus d'un mois
plus tard ils l'ont violé juste devant
chez elle lorsque sa mère a voulu la
sauver sa fille a crié de ne pas
s'approcher pour protéger sa mère
[Musique]
et puis il y a l'histoire de cet enfant
de 11 ans c'est sa mère que j'ai reçu
son fils a été violée dans leur maison
par deux hommes devant sa mère elle
était attachée sur une chaise et son
enfant a été violée sous ses yeux désolé
mais c'est la réalité c'était aboucha
il a aussi été violemment battu il a été
conduit dans un hôpital aussi rapidement
que possible il aurait fallu que ce soit
plutôt encore mais il est maintenant
hospitalisé à Kiev
la plupart des femmes et des enfants qui
ont subi ces viols ne parleront
malheureusement jamais estime la
psychologue ni au psychologue encore
moins aux enquêteurs parmi ces patientes
certains lui parlent n'ont pas de porter
plainte mais de suicide
difficile de repartir après ces
témoignages que vous avez recueilli
Maureen Mercier envoyé spécial RTS en
Ukraine merci pour votre travail sur le
terrain où il est essentiel d'être
présent
il est effectivement très difficile de
reprendre la parole après tous ces
témoignages complètement
bouleversants
néanmoins je vous propose que nous
continuons nos travaux comme nous
l'avions prévu en écoutant donc en
vision conférence Catarina chez répateur
qui est présidente de la strada donc ONG
on n'arrive pas à se connecter donc on a
un reportage
aux questions
une matinée compliquée mais je ne doute
pas que vous aurez beaucoup de questions
à poser à nos intervenantes et je vous
donne par conséquent la parole
qui merci Martine filleule sénatrice du
Nord pour l'animation de cette table
ronde forcément après de tels
témoignages c'est difficile pour vous
tous d'encaisser mais à partir du moment
où on écoute on entend on est obligé
aussi de réagir et de se dire que on
doit pouvoir agir et c'était c'est
vraiment le sens aussi de cette table
ronde ce matin pour se dire comment agir
Amnesty International et vous madame mon
anglais étant plus difficile je vais
faire wwo W ça va être plus simple je
vais vous éviter de vous faire grincer
les oreilles dès le matin donc ce qui
sera intéressant maintenant c'est
d'avoir peut-être vos réactions à vous
les membres de la commission des
affaires étrangères les membres de
l'association de la Sorbonne les
sénatrices et sénateurs membres de la
délégation qui nous ont rejoints et puis
je sais qu'il y a quelques élus de
départements puisqu'il profite du
Congrès faire la Haute-Savoie la Vendée
également il profite de ce congrès des
mers pour nous avoir rejoint et cette
échappée du brouhaha et revenir à des
questions peut-être plus internationales
donc est-ce que dans la salle là je vous
ai laissé le temps de
digérer ce témoignage violent est-ce que
est-ce que après ce témoignage qu'on a
entendu tous religieusement je suis
persuadé que s'il y avait eu
200-300 personnes dans la salle il y
aura pas eu un bruit de plus
donc notre collègue je vois pas assis
notre collègue de membre de la
délégation et de la commission des
affaires étrangères également la
sénatrice chevalariom et l'âme merci oui
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente moi
je voudrais vous dire évidemment mais je
n'ai pas besoin de vous le dire combien
ces témoignages sont totalement
bouleversants même si effectivement bon
je suis également ces questions depuis
très longtemps je suis bon je m'étais un
peu spécialisée sur ces questions là et
au sein de l'Assemblée parlementaire de
l'OTAN à laquelle j'appartiens et que je
préside d'ailleurs depuis deux jours je
présidais une commission sur
la dimension civile de la sécurité nous
avons toujours travaillé sur cette
question des femmes de la sécurité de
l'application de la résolution 13 25 en
faisant de nombreux colocs conférences
bon j'en ai fait un petit peu partout
dans plusieurs pays et effectivement la
grande question et c'est ça le plus
important comment faire alors déjà merci
merci de ce que vous faites parce que
c'est extrêmement important parce qu'il
faut le faire savoir et vous aviez
raison mesdames en disant ce n'est pas
suffisamment connu c'est un sujet qui
est occulté personne n'en parle parce
que souvent ne veut pas le voir et
c'était souvent le dernier des aspects
que l'on aborde quand on parle de guerre
de conflits
alors que faire bon déjà cette dimension
femme et sécurité et inclus dans nos
travaux au sein de la commission des
affaires étrangères et de la défense du
Sénat sur le développement parce que
c'est très important pendant très
longtemps les femmes ont été totalement
cultés je sais que pendant des années
j'ai réclamé qu'on puisse flécher des
aides spécifiquement pour les femmes sur
le développement maintenant c'est fait
mais il faut aller plus loin pour vous
donner un exemple bon j'étais tout ce
week-end donc à notre session
d'assemblée parlementaire de l'OTAN avec
des ukrainiennes des députés
ukrainiennes et
ukrainiens et il y a dix jours j'ai vu
et je suppose que vous êtes en contact
avec elle la prix Nobel de la paix que
j'ai rencontrée il y a 15 jours
Alexandra maître absolument
extraordinaire c'est pour ça qu'elle a
eu d'ailleurs ce prix Nobel de la paix
et elle nous parlait je la voyais avec
la présidente de la délégation
du un groupe d'amitié francs sucrées
elle nous parlait de son travail sur le
terrain j'ai essayé d'ailleurs de la
joindre mais malheureusement apparemment
les communications sont coupées avec
l'Ukraine j'ai pas pu la joindre parce
que j'aurais bien aimé qu'elle puisse
aussi apporter un témoignage que
j'aurais pu vous donner elle nous
parlait de ses énormes difficultés et
même pour elle parce que c'est
extrêmement dur de voir ce qu'elle voit
tous les jours de recueillir ces
témoignages qu'elle
recueille mais elle tient absolument le
faire parce que le but est le but
premier c'est d'obtenir extrêmement
rapidement la création d'un tribunal
international pour juger au plus vite
ces crimes de guerre mais pour cela bien
sûr il faut un maximum de témoignages
chez toute la difficulté donc c'est
quelque chose que nous réclamons que
nous avons encore réclamé
lors de cette session de l'Assemblée
parlementaire de l'OTAN lors de mon
discours d'acceptation du poste de
président de j'ai insisté sur le fait
que nous devons reconnaître le fait que
les Russes travaillent comme des sons
des terroristes actuellement ce sont des
méthodes de terrorisme quand on viole
les femmes quand on les assassine c'est
une barbarie que l'on ne peut pas
accepter il faut aussi que les
dérigeants soient jugés et surtout au
plus vite parce que la justice prend
énormément de temps on ne peut pas
attendre des années et Alexandra et ses
députés nous disaient le gros problème
en Ukraine pardon je me focalise sur
l'Ukraine mais évidemment il y a
d'autres terrains qui sont aussi
évidemment très important mais bon là on
est vraiment aussi dans l'actualité le
problème c'est l'impunité les soldats
russes c'est violeurs sont persuadés que
jamais ils n'iront devant un tribunal et
quand ces femmes essaient de leur en
parler c'est le déni total d'où
l'importance d'agir très très vite et ça
voilà je crois que c'est
vraiment fondamental et
il faut continuer ce qu'on nous
demandait aussi ce que Alexandra medwich
nous demander c'était d'obtenir j'essaie
d'agir un petit peu dans le sens que
nous ayons plus de gendarmes pour
recueillir les témoignages mais surtout
qu'il reste aussi plus longtemps pour
rassurer la population parce que c'est
très clair les femmes ont peur elles
n'ont plus confiance en quiconque
aujourd'hui et voilà pardon j'ai un peu
trop longue mais je voulais simplement
vous remercier du travail exceptionnel
que vous faites du courage que vous avez
et parce que c'est très important et je
crois que tous ici on a tous envie de
vous aider on veut aller plus loin et
j'en profite pour remercier notre
président technique billon de cette
excellente idée de cette conférence
merci
merci chers collègues alors les idées ne
viennent pas que de moi nous sommes dans
une commission délégation et tous les
sujets sont partagés et portés par les
membres de la délégation et je
souhaiterais pas m'attribuer cette
organisation en plus nous sommes aidés
évidemment par l'administration du Sénat
donc merci plutôt pour ce témoignage moi
je comme il y avait pas véritablement de
questions dans le témoignage de notre
collègue Joël guerrier mesdames je
voudrais peut-être juste vous demander
mesdames
on sait souvent que la difficulté de la
lutte contre les violences
intra-famidiales la lutte contre les
violences sexuelles et sexistes quel que
soit qu'elle soit nationale ou qu'elle
soit internationale elle est souvent
question de moyens on l'a vu avec les
travaux que nous avons menés sur Porno
l'enfer du décor à partir du moment où
la justice n'a pas de moyens et pour
mener des enquêtes il faut des moyens
considérables donc est-ce que vous
estimez on parle souvent de diplomatie
féministe qui qui fait partie d'un grand
titre un petit peu pompeux finalement
qu'est-ce qu'il y a derrière cette
diplomatie féministe est-ce qu'il y a
suffisamment de moyens pour les
associations pour la justice vous avez
parlé de tout ce qu'on avait en terme de
structure juridique pour agir de cadre
juridique mais au-delà de cela est-ce
qu'il y a les ressources humaines est-ce
qu'il y a des associations sont en
capacité de faire ce qui ce qui est
demandé pour faire avancer cette lutte
contre les violences sexuelles contre
ces viols de guerre et pour que les
témoignages trouvent enfin un écho parce
que vous l'avez dit un espace d'écoute
c'est bien mais s'il y a juste de
l'écoute s'il y a pas le suivi
l'accompagnement derrière ça sert pas
forcément à grand chose parce que
l'information elle circule mal et
d'ailleurs on le voit puisque l'Ukraine
n'est pas connecté avec nous ce matin
s'il y a d'autres
vice-président du Sénat Monsieur Laurent
qui souhaitait intervenir
oui je voulais juste faire une remarque
et puis poser une question en fait
la première remarque c'est que
tout ce que vous expliquez
une certaine manière qu'on connaît bien
mieux en mieux même si ça n'est pas
suffisamment dénoncé médiatisé
et combattu c'est que le viol est une
arme de guerre quasi systématique c'est
à dire donc quasi la totalité des
conflits armés on est confronté à ça
je le dis parce que ça fait réfléchir
sur sur la guerre
une manière plus générale c'est que on
devrait quand même s'occuper de la
prévention des conflits armés
parce que si le viol est une arme
systématique des conflits armés alors la
prévention des conflits armés devraient
être une toute première priorité auront
plutôt dans une période où on est en
train de banaliser les discours de
guerre
donc ça c'est une remarque un peu
générale
la deuxième chose que je veux dire c'est
concernant nos politiques d'accueil
surtout qu'elles vont être débattues
très prochainement
est-ce que les dispositions actuelles
du droit d'asile et la manière dont nous
mettons en œuvre couvrent suffisamment
bien ces enjeux là ces enjeux de
protection des femmes victimes de
violence et notamment dans les conflits
armés parce que très souvent bon moi je
fais partie de ceux comme beaucoup
probablement d'entre nous qui sont
saisis par des dossiers par des gens qui
ont des dossiers ou qui sont des
dossiers rejetés et on est souvent
confrontés à des situations où ces
personnes malgré des parcours
extrêmement terribles
se trouve écarté des dispositifs d'asile
pour différentes raisons donc
évidemment pour l'Ukraine on a créé
exceptionnellement un statut de
protection temporaire qui a créé des
conditions d'accueil particulières mais
et semble-t-il il va être question pour
les Syriens et pour les Afghans d'un
dispositif de protection subsidiaire
mais est-ce que quand on voit l'ampleur
de ce que vous dites
nous disposons
dans le cadre juridique suffisant pour
prendre en compte ces situations dans
nos dispositifs d'accueil et de
protection et qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
éventuellement modifier pour le prendre
pleinement en compte
que je vais faire c'est que je vais vous
allez noter les questions parce que je
voudrais pas qu'on prenne de retard
parce que il y a des sitateurs qui
animeront les tables rondes suivantes et
qui ont des engagements autre après donc
je vais prendre toutes les questions et
j'en avais une autre de la
vice-présidente et collègue de la
délégation droit des femmes Laurence
Rossignol
merci madame la Présidente merci à
toutes les intervenantes qui nous ont
fait partager ce que pour elle le
quotidien de leur engagement associatif
et politique et qui est insoutenable
disons-le clairement je recherche
peut-être deux remarques et une question
ma première remarque c'est qu'en
écoutant les exigations d'armée
ukrainienne de l'armée russe pardon je
ne peux pas empêcher de me rappeler de
leur filiation avec l'armée soviétique
et ce qui s'est passé à Berlin
à la Libération qu'il ne faut jamais
oublier le viol systématique des femmes
allemandes par les troubles de
libération soviétique et voilà j'y vois
comme une pratique inscrite quasiment
dans l'ADN de ces armées puisque la
filiation est quand même là c'est la
première remarque la deuxième remarque
c'est que c'est pour dire que le viol
est une arme contre les femmes dans les
sociétés non en guerre
voilà et que
ce à quoi ça nous renvoie c'est la
complaisance
ce qu'on appelle la culture du viol dans
le vocabulaire féministe la complaisance
globale des sociétés
même en paix à l'égard de cette guerre
permanente qui est menée par le viol par
le viol par l'instrument des viols
contre les femmes et ma question
concerne les procédures de
demande d'asile et je suis pas loin de
penser que nous devrions demander que
toutes les femmes migrantes
soit considéré comme étant légitime à
l'asile en raison de la présomption qui
pèse sur leur parcours et du fait
qu'elles ont été probablement pour
l'immense majorité d'entre elles
victimes de viol soit à l'origine de
leur départ soit au cours de leur
parcours donc je crois qu'il faudrait
qu'on assume cette idée de toute façon
en plus si on prend le problème
autrement sur les questions de
immigration immigration clandestine etc
c'est pas pardonnez-moi de le dire aussi
crûment mais on a on n'a pas énormément
de femmes qui sont demandeuses d'asile
sol voilà c'est c'est une c'est pas
c'est pas la grande le grand flux des
demandes d'Asie n'est pas sur les femmes
et enfin j'attire notre attention aussi
un peu dans le même esprit de ce que je
disais un instant sur le viol qui existe
aussi dans les CT en paix c'est sur la
place du trafic d'être humain et de la
prostitution en matière de guerre et là
encore
on peut pas défendre une vision glamour
de la prostitution
choisie libre et heureuse
mpowermon des femmes par la prostitution
sans mettre en lien
comment la prostitution est
l'exploitation sexuelle est aussi un
d'une des conséquences des tensions et
de la vulnérabilité des femmes
provoquées dans les périodes de tension
politique voilà donc peut-être un peu
cohérent sur des contrôles à la traite
des êtres humains et des retraites
sexuelles des femmes faut arrêter de
raconter que la prostitution était une
powerande pour les femmes
merci chers collègues je reconnais bien
là l'engagement de au cours de toute son
parcours politique de Laurence Rossignol
et peut-être à toi de laisser la parole
madame Bardet
pas de souci ça va dans la même dans la
même logique que les interventions
précédentes moi je veux je veux quand
même souligner que il semblerait qu'il y
ait une prise de conscience on va dire
mieux partager aujourd'hui
suite justement à ce qui se passe je
pense en Ukraine je veux quand même
attirer l'attention de chacune et chacun
sur le fait que
ça n'est pas
comment dirais-je un phénomène
récent et que il y a eu plusieurs
exemples qui ont été donnés mais quand
on a la chance de rencontrer le docteur
de Nîmes ok
on en apprend beaucoup
et au Congo ça fait plus de 30 ans que
les choses dures dans l'indifférence
quasi générale quand je dis dans
l'indifférence générale ça veut dire que
toute la communauté internationale
finalement c'est totalement détourné de
ce qui pouvait arriver au Congo et des
origines de ce conflit et du fait que
les femmes sont vraiment
au cœur de de de ce conflit en ayant en
subissant des violences absolument
épouvantables je vous encourage à lire
le dernier livre de Denis mokwige la
force des femmes ou il explique bien les
les origines de ce conflit et ils décrit
ce qui est vécu et le combat qu'il doit
qu'il doit mener et il nous interpelle
sur le fait qu'il a besoin toujours lui
et tous ceux qui se dressent en faveur
des victimes et notamment des femmes ils
ont besoin de protection et donc de la
protection aussi international je le
redis parce que c'est un symbole et des
Denis mokuge et il y en a dans d'autres
dans d'autres pays mais lui voilà c'est
c'est un c'est un élément important et
sa parole est forte et on l'entend et on
sait que la reconstruction de de ces
femmes nécessite énormément
d'investissement à tous les niveaux donc
voilà je serais pas plus longue mais
j'attire votre attention et sur la
deuxième chose je pense quand même que
en tout cas ce matin on doit profiter de
cette table ronde aussi pour
effectivement avoir une intervention
plus forte au niveau des femmes
migrantes et des migrations parce que là
c'est quelque chose qui se passe sous
nos yeux je finis Annick ne t'inquiète
pas
ah bon et donc c'est quelque chose qui
se passe sous nos yeux et je trouve que
il y a aussi une grande indifférence et
je le fait que finalement quand même si
on réfléchit ensemble on est dans des
sociétés où
la culture du viol est quand même
répandue et que du coup et ben quand
c'est la guerre finalement c'est la
guerre donc que voilà je je le dis je le
dénonce et il me semble que notre parole
de ce matin les conclusions qu'on peut
en tirer sont sont importantes voilà
très bien merci Laurent je crois que il
y a une personne qui souhaite intervenir
je peux le je vous demande de faire
relativement bref parce que nous sommes
déjà en retard d'accord merci beaucoup
bonjour à toutes et à tous ici moi je
m'appelle Fatima kareemi je suis la
directrice de Kurdistan network
je partage ce que vous avez dire sur la
question de viol pendant
malheureusement en tant que kurde les
cures disons longue histoire sur la
lutte et la Tourtour est souffrances
déjà en Turquie après en série et
actuellement il y a pas de guerre en
Iran mais maintenant il y a une grande
manifestation en Iran sous le slogan de
la femme la loutre la liberté quand on
parle sur la question des femmes pendant
la loutre armée oui on parle sur la
violence et malheureusement à chaque
fois ça se répète même s'il y a des
interventions internationales pour
terminer ce genre de Tourtour sur les
femmes mais malheureusement se répète
mais on parle sur la question des femmes
pendant la lutte armée mais aujourd'hui
on ira on est surtout dans la région
kurde iranienne il y a en grande
manifestation et exactement on a la même
expérience chez les femmes surtout chez
les femmes cultes il y a beaucoup de
femmes qui ont été tués des dizaines de
femmes maisons étaient tuées par
étrangère mais par la République
islamique à l'intérieur de pays il y a
certaines villes cures qu'ils ont
assiégé il y a 10 centaines de femmes
blessés arrêter et selon le CNN il y a
pas mal de femmes qui ont été arrêtés
ils ont été violés où ils étaient
menacés pour d'être violée c'est
pourquoi parfois c'est pas toujours par
les amis étrangère mais parfois à
l'intérieur de pays et ce se répète
c'est pourquoi à mon avis on doit
élargir cette question par juste sur la
lutte être avec les étrangers mais à
l'intérieur de pays aussi et le
gouvernement à l'intérieur de pays il
répète la même chose c'est pourquoi à
mon avis c'est une question très très
large et il faut pas le réduire juste
pendant la lutte avec les étrangers par
exemple comme la femme
ukrainienne qui je partage et je
comprends l'ours souffrance
malheureusement c'est toujours c'est la
même chose voilà juste pour dire que
c'est ça merci de votre témoignage
peut-être est-ce qu'on aura l'occasion
de vous redonner la parole tout à
l'heure dans d'autres tableaux rondes là
je vais donner la parole à nos deux
intervenantes pour qu'elles puissent
réagir aux interventions avec je crois
deux thèmes la question de de l'accueil
de l'asile en France des femmes et puis
la question de la culture du viol en
période de guerre mais aussi en période
j'allais dire normal
merci beaucoup très court je vais faire
très court en essayant de couvrir les
différents champs donc sur la question
de l'accueil sujet qui me tient à cœur
pour avoir travaillé pendant très
longtemps pour la Fuji y compris à la
CNDA d'ailleurs pour le HCR je pense pas
que sur une question de cadre juridique
je pense que le droit est là l'asile le
droit d'asile est un droit
constitutionnel il y a un tas d'un tas
de dispositions européennes et
françaises nationales et internationale
bien sûr qui qui couvre tout à fait ces
cas le problème c'est en amont et
Monsieur Pierre Laurent connaît bien le
sujet c'est l'accès au territoire
faut-il que ces femmes arrivent en
France
il y a la question de l'accord des visas
on a plusieurs dossiers en suspens
notamment sur les femmes afghane donc il
y a la question de l'accès au territoire
par les voies régulières ce qu'on
demande de manière répétée depuis des
années à mystice et que effectivement
les personnes en danger des femmes en
particulier et des voies d'accès
sécurisées au territoire français pour
éviter d'avoir à avoir recours au
passeur avec tout ce qu'on tous enfin
tout ce que vous connaissez sur les
conséquences de ce type de parcours
la question aussi des zones d'attentes
donc une fois que elles arrivent les
demandeurs d'asile arrive au territoire
aux frontières terrestres aériennes en
conflit qui rentre sur les territoires
et ensuite effectivement que les
diffusions de la Convention de Genève la
protection sublière du droit français
soit correctement impliqué à ces femmes
j'aime beaucoup l'idée de Laurence
Rossignol de une reconnaissance prime à
facile à toutes ces familles grandes ce
serait formidable
c'est quelque chose qui existe dans la
Convention de Genève la reconnaissance
prima faciée existe dans certains cas
elle n'est absolument jamais utilisée
elle a quasiment jamais été sauf
peut-être sur le sujet asiatique il y a
très longtemps mais donc effectivement
c'est ça c'est des pistes intéressantes
mais voilà l'accès au territoire et la
demande du visage je pense que c'est une
action aussi doit mener des
parlementaires auprès de l'exécutif que
ce que cette la politique des visas soit
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus ouverte
la question de la de la lutte contre
l'impunité très rapidement autre moyen
alors je vais quand même revenir très
rapidement sur la question de la
compétence universelle ou
extra-territoriale aujourd'hui un auteur
présumé de violences sexuelles qui
soient ukrainien syriens éthiopien
quelque chose nationalité qui arrive en
France il veut pas être arrêté s'il est
s'il est soupçonné de torture il peut
être arrêté parce que la conscience
contre la torture prévoit la compétence
universelle mais s'il est responsable de
crimes de guerre qui montre une unité
crime génocide qui sont les crimes les
plus graves en droit international on
peut rien faire parce que il y a les
fameux trois verrous dont on parle
beaucoup à la coalition française sur la
CPI que je vais vous rappeler très
rapidement et sans aller au-delà sans
discuter plus longtemps mais il y a la
question de l'exigence de résidence
habituelle sur les territoire français
qui est totalement rédhibitoire parce
que fort peu de ces de ces auteurs
présumés sont réside régulièrement sur
le territoire la condition de la double
incrimination qui est encore plus
absurde c'est à dire qu'il faut que dans
le dans le pays d'origine dans le pays
nationalité de l'intéressé enfin de donc
du coupable présumé le crime donc de
guerre contre le mètre caisse soit
également face également partie de
l'arsenal juridique pénal du pays
on parle de la Syrie l'Afghanistan
d'Éthiopie
troisième élément c'est la question du
monopole des poursuites par le parquet
donc il y a que le parquet qui peut
engager des poursuites il peut pas y
avoir de saisines par
l'intéressé ou de participer donc ça
c'est de vous avez d'ailleurs un membre
du Sénat qui est très allant sur ces
questions qui est Monsieur Jean-Pierre
Sueur qui a fait plusieurs propositions
de loi dans ce sens et donc j'encourage
les membres du Sénat qui sont présents à
soutenir ces propulsions de loi pour la
levée de ces trois de ces trois verrous
voilà le dernier élément juste pour
renforcer ce que disait Laurence
Rossignol oui il y a Berlin dont je
reviens et qui était également une
histoire allemande qui me tient à cœur
et puis il y a eu Rosny encore beaucoup
plus récemment il y a les ce qui s'est
passé en Tchétchénie également très
méconnu et qui effectivement assure une
certaine continuité si j'ose dire dans
cette culture de de l'armée russe voilà
sur le reste sur la question la culture
du viol en France je voilà je
m'engagerai pas parce que pour le coup
c'est pas pour moi c'est pas le
la thématique que j'ai préparée
aujourd'hui et je pense que je suis
moins compétente pour en parler
s'impatiente à juste titre parce qu'on a
pris non mais écoutez je vais faire très
très vite d'abord la question de
l'argent
bien sûr qu'il y en a pas assez mais
c'est surtout aussi à qui va l'argent et
je pense qu'il faut essayer d'ouvrir un
peu à des
petites structures à des projets
innovants nous par exemple c'est le
problème qu'on a en fait parce qu'on est
trop petit on est innovant on est voilà
donc on rentre pas donc c'est ça je
pense qu'il faut faciliter les choses et
c'est très fastidieux d'aller demander
de l'argent et là il y a vraiment un
problème deuxièmement alors la
prévention des conflits non mais
tellement parce qu'en fait la question
elle est là et j'ai commencé d'ailleurs
en parlant aussi de dire c'est très lié
à la question de l'État de droit et
c'est très lié à comment on travaille
mieux à la prévention des conflits parce
que une fois qu'il y a un conflit tout
conflit amène des violences sexuelles
voilà donc on le sait puisqu'on de ça
aujourd'hui mais tout le conflit amène
des violences horribles on l'a entendu
sur l'Ukraine partout donc la question
c'est comment on fait pour travailler
mieux sur la prévention des conflits moi
ça je parce que sinon voilà on est
toujours dans la même chose à réparer
comme on peut bref quoi donc si il faut
travailler là-dessus ensuite
la question des femmes migrantes oui en
fait il y a aussi la notion de de
vulnérabilité il y a la jurisprudence de
la CNDA mais je pense que un des
problèmes aussi qu'il y a c'est qu'il y
a un manque de formation et de
compréhension par exemple on a beaucoup
de requérantes et tout qui ont beaucoup
de mal à parler du viol ou qui ont des
traumas et en France Muriel salmonas si
quelqu'un qui parle beaucoup de ça cette
psychiatre et qu'on me dissociation donc
et souvent les juges et comprendre ils
comprennent pas ce genre très là il y a
quelques jours j'ai une irakienne de
kirkoek mais en fait elle rigolait elle
a et en fait ça c'est des choses
dissociation qui sont liées au trauma
mais en fait en face les juges ils
comprennent pas donc ils considèrent
c'est pas crédible ce qu'elle dit donc
il y a un travail à faire là dessus qui
est énorme qui est extrêmement important
et nous un des projets moi que j'avais
aussi pour wher c'est qu'on aimerait
aussi devenir une organisation de
référence vers lesquelles les migrantes
les femmes migrantes qui effectivement
reste minoritaire pourrait venir nous on
pourrait faire ces entretiens avec elle
et faire des sortes de je sais pas
comment dire ça pas de certificat mais
mais voilà de de de documents qui puisse
soutenir
le fait qu'elles aient été violées
ensuite
les Alliés oui et la culture de la
violence dans les forces militaires
russes évidemment juste une chose sur
l'Ukraine parce que justement c'est
Alexandra qui a notamment parlé m'a
parlé de ça de la problématique de la
fuite entre guillemets de ces
témoignages et de la difficulté de
suivre en fait les femmes ukrainiennes
qui partent et donc il faut mettre en
place des choses et d'ailleurs lié aux
migrants c'est la même chose donc c'est
pour ça que nous on travaille avec cet
outil là et je pense qu'il faut
à permettre à ces gens là de pouvoir
donner leur témoignages c'est au-delà
donner leur témoignages c'est dire on
est là et de pouvoir être suivi combien
il y a de personnes qui arrivent sur le
territoire français qui ont vécu
d'amende dans la route de l'exil des
violences sexuelles terribles et qui
sont pas pris en charge mais parce qu'on
le sait même pas en fait donc il y a un
vrai travail à faire là dessus donc il y
a plein de choses à faire donc n'hésitez
pas à venir nous solliciter maintenant
il faut des moyens moi j'ai 1000 idées
il y a plein de choses sur lesquelles
j'aimerais travailler mais j'ai pas les
moyens de le faire donc donc c'est aussi
là dessus qu'il faut qu'il faut
travailler et merci Madame pour la
question kurde parce que bien sûr bien
sûr et dernière chose oui c'est
important aussi vous avez raison on
parle des femmes actrices c'est comment
on fait aussi pour aider les personnes à
l'intérieur parce que comme je disais
aussi la question des victimes elles
savent ce qu'il faut faire c'est comment
on fait pour nous on travaille avec des
points focaux intérieurs on travaille
beaucoup on est en sorte de parapluie on
n'a pas une équipe à Paris on travaille
vraiment avec des gens sur le terrain et
comment on fait pour capacité ces gens
là parce que c'est eux qui changent
aussi leur pays vous avez parlé du livre
de Denis mon courrier l'empire du
silence le film de Thierry Michel sur la
République démocratique du Congo que
j'encourage tout le monde à voir parce
que quand vous avez vu ce film enfin moi
je pourtant je vois beaucoup de choses
dans ma vie mais franchement il est
assez incroyable et je suis d'accord
avec vous mais les femmes aussi
congolaises maintenant elles montent au
créneau donc c'est c'est aussi ça qu'il
faut capacité c'est tous ces réseaux là
qu'il faut et il faut les capacités il
faut les aider au lexandra le fait ce
travail en Ukraine mais elle a pas elle
a pas complètement les compétences donc
c'est ça qui demande donc c'est ça qu'il
faut qu'on appuie voilà merci beaucoup
grand merci à vous pour votre action et
vos témoignages je pense que nous allons
mettre fin à notre première table ronde
sans tarder car nous avons déjà pris je
crois
un peu de retard merci madame la
Présidente vous excusez merci merci
à vous mesdames à vous et à notre
collègue Martine filleul qui a animé
cette première table ronde donc la
sénatrice du Nord et donc je vais passer
maintenant j'ai demandé à Max Brisson
sénateur des Pyrénées Atlantiques de
nous rejoindre qui va animer cette
deuxième table ronde et vous avez fait
madame Bardet le lien puisque vous avez
vous nous avez dit pardon comment on
fait et bien on va tenter d'y répondre
avec cette deuxième table ronde puisque
c'est la prise en charge des femmes
victimes de violence en temps de guerre
merci pour cette première séquence qui
était à la fois
intéressante mais aussi
qui ne nous a pas laissé de marbre avec
ses témoignages et la réalité des choses
donc shermax Brisson avoue la parole
pour information à la délégation au
droit des femmes il y a des femmes
engagées mais il y a aussi des hommes
engagés et voilà des hommes en à nos
côtés parce que toutes ces questions
elles concernent les hommes et les
femmes à vous chers collègues merci
chers présidente bonjour chacune et
chacun d'entre vous et je souhaite la
bienvenue au 4 intervenants de cette
deuxième tableau ronde alors consacré à
la prise en charge des femmes victimes
de violences en temps de guerre nous
allons parler de prise en charge mais je
suis bien d'accord avec ce qui a été dit
tout à l'heure après l'intervention de
Pierre Laurent l'essentiel bien sûr est
dans la prévention des potes de
prévention la prise en charge est
nécessaire donc je voudrais vous
présenter Ghislaine Doucet conseiller
juridique principale pour la délégation
régionale du Comité international de la
Croix-Rouge à Paris je voudrais vous
présenter le Docteur Thomas charbonnier
gynécologue obstétricien et
administrateurs de gynécologue sans
frontières et Michel P directrice de
l'éducation de l'impact et de la
recherche au sein de l'ONG bibliothèque
sans pierre BSF qui vient de signer un
partenariat avec la Représentante
spéciale du Secrétaire général des
Nations unies chargées de la question
des violences sexuelles commises en
période de conflit ce partenariat repose
notamment sur une approche holistique
pour les survivantes et sur l'expertise
développée promesse dans l'organisation
d'espace sécurisé au sein desquelles les
survivantes aux violences sexuelles
pourront avoir accès à des services de
soutien médical psychologique juridiques
ainsi qu'à des activités éducatives et
des formations professionnelles et puis
je voudrais vous présenter elle va
intervenir en visioconférence depuis la
République démocratique du Congo Justine
Masika biyamba présidente de l'ONG
synergie des femmes pour les victimes de
violences sexuelles qui œuvrent pour
protéger les femmes victimes et
violences plus particulièrement dans le
Nord qui vous province comme vous le
savez de l'Est de la RDC de la
République démocratique du Congo
merci à vous Mesdames et Monsieur et
docteur pour votre participation ce
matin à cette table ronde nous allons
vous entendre avec un grand intérêt par
les actions concrètes et des programmes
entreprises par les différentes
organisations que vous représentez afin
de prendre en charge les fables victimes
de violence en temps de guerre nous
savons bien sûr que les séquelles
physiques comme psychologiques sont
considérables on en a eu illustration
c'est lourd d'acide à entendre tout à
l'heure elles sont considérantes elles
sont considérables eux-mêmes d'ailleurs
que les conséquences économiques et
sociales il est donc fondamental que les
victimes soient reconnues d'abord comme
victime de guerre et qu'elle bénéficie
de l'assistance médicale psychologique
juridique et matériel qu'implique leur
situation
médicale les victimes doivent pouvoir
bénéficier de soins de son médico
généraux de chirurgie réparatrice
d'accompagnement psychologique voire
psychiatrique la dimension juridique
ensuite il est indispensable de former
des professionnels Avocats juriste force
de l'ordre à des méthodes d'enquêtes et
d'écoute des victimes précises et
efficaces afin d'entamer des poursuites
du juridique et de condamner les
bourreaux à cet égards la question de la
collecte de preuves en matière de
violence sexuelle commise dans le cadre
de conflits et primordial jugé ces
crimes constituent une étape
indispensable à la reconstruction des
victimes enfin la dimension matérielle
il s'agit de soutenir la réhabilitation
économique et sociale des femmes
survivantes leur construction passe en
effet par la construction de leur
autonomie
donc merci
mesdames docteur de répondre dans votre
intervention aux questions suivantes
estimez-vous que nous avons progressé
dans l'aide à portée aux victimes à la
fois immédiate et soutien plus long
terme pour les aider à se reconstruire
qu'en est-il des finances aujourd'hui le
délira pour d'activité du Secrétaire
général de l'ONU indique que la part de
l'aide bilatérale à l'égalité des sexes
dans les contextes fragiles et touchés
par les conflits restent à de 5% et lors
d'une table ronde qui avait été
organisée en 2019 au Sénat les
participants avaient également évoqué
des défaillances liées à l'utilisation
et la répartition de l'aide allouée aux
victimes ces critiques sont-elles
toujours d'actualité alors que nous
examinons d'ailleurs actuellement le
projet de loi de financement 2023 ces
questions de financement sont bien sûr
dans tous les esprits et donc je laisse
sans plus tarder la parole Ghislaine
Doucet du Comité international de la
Croix-Rouge
merci beaucoup
madame et merci d'inviter le CIC à
participer à cette à cette journée de
réflexion et dans journée dans laquelle
je vais plutôt mettre l'accent si vous
voulez bien sûr les dispositions
justement du droit international
humanitaire donc le droit applicable
dans les conflits armés
pourquoi ça peut paraître un peu naïf
peut-être de dire ça mais j'aime bien en
revenir parfois au fondamentaux et
surtout quand j'ai entendu tous les
échanges qui ont eu lieu dans la
précédente table ronde je pense qu'il
est important de dire haut et fort que
les femmes dans les conflits armés ont
des droits que ces droites tiennent
compte de leurs besoins spécifiques et
que donc il existe un cadre juridique
contraignant obligatoire tant pour les
belligérants je vais y revenir dans un
instant que pour l'ensemble des États
qui sont d'ailleurs partis aux
Conventions de Genève on pourrait penser
que cela va sans dire mais je crois que
ça va mieux en le disant et cela permet
ensuite de mieux répondre aux questions
que vous vous posez sur l'établissement
des responsabilités la recherche des
responsables et aussi la question des
réparations
je veux donc dire qu'on ne part pas de
rien on parle de disposition qui existe
et depuis longtemps et je pense aussi
que le droit international humanitaire
en période de confirmer comme d'autres
normes comme le droit international des
droits de l'homme le droit des réfugiés
un peu évoqué tout à l'heure
répondre en fait de façon plutôt
adéquate j'allais dire au besoin des
femmes qui se trouvent dans ces
situations
autrement dit le défi
consiste à
traduire le droit en pratique par divers
moyens et lorsque le droit n'est pas
respecté donc à mettre en jeu les
responsabilités et donc
si à travailler énormément à la
prévention bien sûr des violences là je
ne parle pas de la prévention des
conflits armés comme le sénateur tout à
l'heure parce que ça va beaucoup plus
loin mais en tous les cas il y a tout un
travail pour prévenir les violences et
je m'empresse de dire que cela aussi est
une obligation endroit international
humanitaire et la prévention c'est aussi
on en a parlé un peu tout à l'heure
c'est modifier les comportements c'est
comprendre l'origine de ces
comportements et à cet égard le CICR a
travaillé sur ces questions et à publier
différentes brochures sur les
comportements des et les origines de ce
comportement des belligérant dans les
conflits armés et puis enfin puisque
j'en parle le CICR comme vous le savez
est un acteur un peu particulier dans
dans les conflits armés ils dispose d'un
mandat qui lui a été conféré par les 196
états partis aux Conventions de Genève
pour veiller au bon respect de ce droit
international humanitaire et dans ce
cadre il porte naturellement une
attention particulière aux femmes et aux
violations que les délégués constatent
sur le terrain quel que soit les
conflits armés et il n'y a pas que les
conflits armés qui ont été cités tout à
l'heure c'est bien une constante dans
tout dans tous les conflits armés
concernant spécifiquement les femmes le
saisisseur a beaucoup travaillé
travaillent encore bien sûr
à développer divers outils qui sont
spécifiques ou qui sont oui qui sont
particulièrement qui sont particuliers
pardon pour répondre aux besoins
spécifiques des femmes dans les dans les
conflits armés et je vous citerai
notamment le guide pratique qui
s'appelle répondre aux besoins des
femmes affectées par les conflits armés
qui s'inscrit dans le cadre d'une d'une
grande série j'allais dire d'études
conduites par le CICR notamment depuis
2001 où il avait publié une étude qui
s'appelait les femmes face à la guerre
et qui analysent l'impact en fait des
conflits armés sur les femmes de manière
générale c'est pas réduit aux violences
sexuelles et puis je voulais vous
signaler à cet égard un nouveau rapport
mais il n'est pour l'instant disponible
qu'en anglais qui est paru en juin 2022
sur cette fois-ci l'impact des conflits
armés mais en partant sous l'angle du
genre et pas seulement sous l'angle des
femmes donc avant d'entrer dans plus de
détails et sous réserve que j'en ai le
temps je voulais juste quelques
remarques d'abord et il y en a qui ont
été dites déjà pardon je voudrais dire
que les problèmes que rencontre les
femmes dans les conflits armés ne sont
ni une fatalité ni un aspect donc qui
est oublié en tout cas oublier d'énormes
que les violences que les femmes
endurent dans les conflits armés sont de
divers ordres alors bien sûr on pense en
premier lieu et c'était de la Table
Ronde précédente on pense bien sûr tout
de suite aux violences sexuelles mais je
vous laisse souligner qu'il y a bien
d'autres formes de violence physique et
et mental qui sont d'ailleurs liés les
unes aux autres et qui pourraient être
largement évitées si le droit
international humanitaire était respecté
je prends un seul exemple si un
bombardement illicite fait que l'eau est
coupée vous obligez les femmes à aller
chercher l'eau en utilisant des d'autres
comment dire des moyens peu sûr des
lieux peu sûrs pour se déplacer donc
vous multipliez les risques d'agression
sexuelle c'est qu'un exemple mais ça
veut dire que si on ne respecte pas si
les belligérants ne respectent pas les
normes relatives à la conduite des
hostilités alors vous avez une cascade
ensuite de conséquences et donc de
violence possible
avec évidemment des risques d'agression
sexuelles dans la vie tout à l'heure
ce que l'on peut relever aussi ce que et
ça a été dit puisque les femmes sont
souvent exposées
elles sont souvent exposées à des
risques accrus en temps de conflit parce
que déjà en temps de paix elles sont
victimes de discrimination ça a été dit
je crois que c'est important de le
répéter et donc on le sait en temps de
guerre les inégalités qui existent déjà
sont exacerbées qui que l'on parle
d'emploi que l'on parle de sécurité
économique bref un certain nombre de
choses
je l'ai dit la prévention et la sanction
des violations quelles qu'elles soient
relève en premier lieu des belligérants
quand je dis belliférence ça veut dire
des États mais je parle aussi des
groupes armés n'en éthiques mais je veux
souligner qu'elle relève aussi encore
une fois de tous les états même ceux qui
ne sont pas partis au conflit donc les
États d'inôtres qui ont l'obligation de
faire respecter le droit international
humanitaire
comme pour toute victime bien sûr
réparation des préjudices subis cela est
essenti cela essentiel c'est aussi une
obligation du VIH ça a été dit et redit
je crois que c'est une bardée a mis
aussi l'accent sur le fait que la
réparation ce n'est pas une seule voie
c'est pas uniquement le procès pénal
c'est le principe base on a plusieurs
plusieurs voiles la réparation peut se
manifester de diverses façons soit de
manière cumulée soit de manière
individuelle donc le procès pénale
l'indemnisation la restauration dans
l'état intérieur et la réhabilitation
physique etc un autre point sur lequel
je voulais mettre l'accent c'est que
lorsqu'on parle des femmes cela englobe
bien sûr aussi les jeunes filles on en a
pas parlé tout à l'heure on a parlé un
petit peu lorsqu'on parlait lors des
témoignages
sur les sur les viols mais évidemment
dans le monde entier les jeunes filles
sont exposées à ce type d'agression
qu'elle soit physique ou
psychologique et puis évidemment on va
voir une pensée particulière pour les
jeunes filles enlevées par Boko Haram au
Nigéria mais je pense aussi aux petites
filles qui se trouvent aussi en série
dans les camps de halol la liste n'est
pas exhaustive et donc juste pour dire
que là aussi pour elle les les
dispositions qui s'appliquent
particulièrement aux enfants
s'appliquent en plus évidemment des
dispositions protectrices protectrice
des femmes à toutes ces à toutes ces
filles et jeunes filles et puis pour les
filles et jeunes filles ce qui va
m'amener au troisième point c'est qu'il
ne faut pas oublier que dans que parmi
ces jeunes filles il y en a un certain
nombre comme de jeunes garçons
d'ailleurs qui sont enroulé de force
dans les dans les dans les combats par
des États ou par des groupes armées
nonétatiques et que donc dans ce cadre
aussi elles vont bénéficier d'une
protection particulière il ne faut pas
l'oublier ce sont avant tout des
victimes lorsqu'elles sont enrôlées de
force et qu'elle combattent
et donc c'est la mamène à ce point où je
voulais souligner que les femmes dans
les conflits armés ne sont pas seulement
des victimes ou ne sont pas seulement
des victimes passives beaucoup sont
actives et aussi je voulais mettre
l'accent ça peut être un peu esquisser
tout à l'heure sur le cas pardon des
femmes combattantes et du reste je dois
dire que le droit international
humanitaire et les règles qui existent
aujourd'hui qui sont protectrices des
femmes en tant que femme en tant que
mère ou en tant que détenus prisonnier
de guerre en fait trouve leur origine au
départ dans la convention de 1929 sur
les prisonniers de guerre où là on
s'était rendu compte que lors de la
Première Guerre mondiale il y avait
beaucoup de femmes qui combattaient qui
soutenaient etc et c'est comme ça qu'en
fait on a pensé à introduire une
protection spécifique pour les femmes
prisonnières de guerre et ensuite cette
protection a été étendue aux femmes en
général qui sont qui sont dans les
conflits dans les conflits armés donc je
vais passer bien sûr tous les les
comment dire les les dispositions
particulière du droit international
humanitaire qui protège spécialement les
femmes ou qui les protègent en tant que
personne civile mais sur ce dernier
point juste pour mettre l'accent pour
dire que
je l'ai un peu esquissé tout à l'heure
au regard de la conduite des hostilités
donc comme vous savez il y a une
protection générale des civils contre la
conduite des hostilités et
si ce n'est pas respecté ce sont les
femmes qui vont subir en premier lieu
les conséquences pourquoi parce que vous
avez parlé de la guerre en Ukraine tout
à l'heure on voit bien les hommes sont
au combat mais c'est partout pareil les
sommes sont au Cobas pour les plupart
donc ce sont les femmes qui restent à
l'arrière donc ce sont les femmes qui
sont finalement les chefs de famille
donc ce sont elles qui vont subir de
plein fouet les bombardements des écoles
les bombardements des hôpitaux le fait
qu'il y ait l'électricité l'eau coupée
les déplacements de population par les
des migrants tout à l'heure les
déplacements de population c'est en
grande partie des femmes ou des
personnes âgées des vieillards parce que
les encore une fois les hommes sont au
combat quand ils sont pas morts etc donc
ce sont les femmes qui vont subir de
plein fouet en fait vraiment les
l'irrespects des normes les règles
relatives à la conduite des hostilités
un dernier mot parce que je pense que je
vais arriver au bout de mes 10 minutes
parce que je suis pas mon chronomètre
sous les yeux il y a beaucoup de choses
à dire
et je le d'autant plus que je vous vois
que je vous vois en face c'est que
tout cela évidemment est pris en compte
on travaille avec le général alors en
France bien sûr c'est prises en compte
si je pense je reviens en violence
sexuelle il y a eu on a fait pendant
plusieurs années avec le ministère des
armées un certain nombre de de comment
dire de sessions spéciales sur les sur
les violences sexuelles voilà il y a un
certain nombre de moyens aussi qui qui
permettent et qui ont été développées
dans le cadre de programme du CICA que
je peux pas vous développer ici en
pratique mais comme nous sommes partout
nous en développons beaucoup de
programmes d'action mais il y a
différentes voix donc évidemment il y a
la sensibilisation il y a l'enseignement
il y a aussi s'agissant de violences
sexuelles de programmes particulier y
compris vers les personnels humanitaires
d'autres organismes pour les pour
apprendre à apprendre en charge
accueillir etc etc les femmes les autres
moyens bien sûr c'est ce que nous
utilisons c'est le dialogue avec les
belligérants donc état ou groupe armés
n'en étatique donc
d'abord pour insister sur l'accès aux
victimes parce que l'accès est un
c'est une obligation pour les belles
différentes nous laisser passer l'accès
aussi au ravitaillement ce corps
humanitaire etc etc voilà donc pardon
c'est extrêmement résumé tout ça et très
très
bref mais je pense qu'il y aura
peut-être des questions tout à l'heure
merci Madame Doucet pour cette
intervention
au docteur charbonnier pardon de bien
vouloir l'ouvrir pour pouvoir
entamer l'intervention suivante je vous
donne la parole Docteur Thomas
charbonnier de gynécologie sans
frontières bien merci mesdames les
sénatrices monsieur le sénateurs
mesdames et messieurs tout d'abord je
tenais à vous remercier pour cet
invitation qui nous donne de la
visibilité c'est très important pour
nous nous sommes une petite ONG et
paradoxalement
on a beaucoup de travail dans le monde
et nous sommes nous avons une expertise
gynéco et obstétricale quasi exclusive
dans le monde la plupart du temps ce
sont les sociétés savantes et si on
cherche des finances c'est plus parce
qu'on est mauvais en com et qu'on
s'adapte plus sur nos missions
j'ai fait une présentation je vois que
je suis le seul hein c'était plus pour
les images donc je sais pas si on l'a la
présentation vous l'avez
sinon je peux faire ça mais c'est plus
pour les images alors je vous rassure
tout de suite c'est des images qu'on
manie avec précaution c'est des images
de contexte et de mission évidemment non
des images médicales qui sont souvent
assez brutales et plus techniques sur la
page c'est pas grave je vais faire ça
donc rapidement pour aller plus dans le
vif du ciel on va parler plus de la
technique et de ce qu'on peut proposer
nous en termes d'accompagnement à super
c'est mieux sur les sur le terrain
nous travaillons beaucoup avec le
professeur muquier dont on a parlé tout
à l'heure qui est un ami de gynéco sans
frontières et comme il le dit lui-même
réparer une femme chirurgicalement pour
reprendre les termes médiatiques c'est
extrêmement difficile et c'est ce qui
est plus facile à faire
quand on englobe la dimension
psychologique comme il le dit aussi on
les guérit jamais en fait on peut les
soutenir donc finalement la chirurgie
c'est la part la plus visible et la plus
simple à faire
on va en reparler après alors est-ce que
ça marche oui donc je nous présente
rapidement
donc
GSF est une presque voilà
on teste matériel donc voilà donc nous
sommes une ong qui est écrit en 95 sur
l'initiative de d'un groupe de
sage-femme et de médecins qui se sont
alertés sur la condition des femmes dans
le monde notamment par l'insuffisance
d'accès aux soins sous toutes forme que
ce soit c'est à dire sous les dimensions
médicales mais aussi psychologique
juridique également tout ce qui peut
toucher les femmes nous intéressent et
nous tentons nous déplacer en suivant
l'actualité sur tous les terrains qui
existent il y a l'Afrique classique etc
je vous montre une petite carte après
donc nous allons toucher à tout ce qui
peut toucher des femmes c'est à dire la
périnatalité les souffrances médicales
psychologiques les violences
intrafamiliales les violences conjugales
mais aussi toutes les discriminations de
toutes sortes et bien entendu ce qui
nous intéresse aujourd'hui les violences
sexuelles à en zone de conflit il faut
bien comprendre que dès qu'un conflit ou
même d'ailleurs c'est pareil pour un
séisme les premières victimes c'est les
femmes et les enfants puisque c'est les
plus fragiles et ce sont des cibles
juste pour cadrer un petit peu donc ça
c'est un exemple de mission qu'on fait
c'est pas exhaustif nous sommes en
Rwanda d'ailleurs nous en revenons
fraîchement il y a quelques jours sur le
camp de Mahama 2 nous sommes beaucoup en
République démocratique du Congo à
panzzi et au théma qui est dans le
centre de la province du sang Courau au
centre du de la RDC au Cameroun en
Centrafrique avec Alima on Togo aussi
nous sommes en France depuis 2014 pour
des raisons dont on va parler après dont
on a déjà parlé d'ailleurs et puis là
les projets à venir on va peut-être
intégrer os Méditerranée pour pour les
femmes toujours
donc là vous avez une petite carte de où
nous sommes c'est plus visuel voilà donc
il y a des missions passées des missions
à venir
et puis ça ce sont toutes les missions
passées c'est pour vous donner une idée
on avait commencé au Mali au Burkina
Faso et en 99 au Kosovo c'est comme ça
on peut qu'on a initié nos premières
missions et on va partout on nous
appelle parce qu'en général on nous
appelle et c'est ce qui s'est passé dans
le Nord d'ailleurs sur la jungle de
Calais c'est une sage-femme Alexandra
duth qui nous a appelé un jour en disant
vous savez ce que vous faites à
l'international vous l'avez juste au
dessus de chez vous et effectivement on
a retrouvé pour une partie certaines
conditions qu'on avait ailleurs voir en
pire dans les camps du Nord
alors ça c'est pour la presse donc la
presse nous appelle aussi beaucoup ici
aujourd'hui assez facile de trouver des
articles qui passent justement de
qui parlent des violences sexuelles dans
le monde dans les conflits armés et on
en a parlé pour l'Ukraine aussi c'est
toujours d'actualité et effectivement
dès qu'il y a un conflit ces
systématique ça existe déjà d'ailleurs
avant le 19e siècle dès qu'il y a un
conflit il y a des viols qui vont s'y
associer donc je passe rapidement pour
aller plus sur l'action de terrain on
pourra en parler des heures la RDC on en
a déjà parlé donc sur le Kivu
effectivement
moi je veux juste préciser le chiffre
qu'on avait eu de l'unhr et puis aussi
même le professeur mukugan nous en parle
en termes de viol c'est-à-dire qu'on
parle uniquement de viol on pense qu'il
y a 500 000 victimes à peu près les
docteurs miquelier en 2004 signalait
qu'il opérait 4000 femmes par an et
aujourd'hui 2500 donc c'est moins mais
comme il le dit lui-même les métastases
sont là et on est loin d'arriver à zéro
on parle aussi rapidement du Rwanda
parce que sur les camps de maammar donc
là j'ai mis deux rapports un de plans
international ça c'est un interrogène
qui date de 2016 on voit pas trop il
souligne le fait qu'il y a une majorité
de femmes et d'enfants dans les camps de
Mama 1 et 2 et en 2019 on ressentait
400000 personnes il y a une
surpopulation et une grande promiscuité
donc il y a beaucoup de violences
sexuelles ce qu'ils appellent les
violences de genre sur dans le rapport
de plan
sur les adolescentes les enfants les
femmes sous toutes formes que ce soit
c'est à dire mariage forcé grossesse
forcés rapports sexuel précoce etc et
donc on a été alerté sur le camp de 1 et
2 parce que initialement on attendait 50
000 personnes et on est à 500 000
aujourd'hui et donc ils ont créé un
deuxième camp sachant que le premier a
été créé en 2015 et on a beaucoup
travaillé avec Maggie baron sight on a
pas encore parlé mais qui est une la
surnomme l'ange du Burundi
cette femme a du furent sans pays en
2015 justement parce qu'elle avait créé
la Maison Shalom et entre autres elle
était très opposante et là énormément
contribué à protéger les femmes et les
enfants
voilà ça c'est juste pour vous situer le
camp de ma main au roi Lille au sud-est
du Rwanda la frontière burundaise
sans s'attarder les actions alors nous
avons trois types d'actions pour ce qui
nous concerne aujourd'hui ce qui a bien
d'autres bien sûr l'action de terrain
qui consiste à envoyer des équipes sur
place et à agir à opérer qu'on envoie
des chirurgiens mais aussi des
sages-femmes c'est très important quand
vous avez une quand vous allez sur des
violences sexuelles vous aurez forcément
un soutien psychologique qui englobe la
femme sous toutes ses dimensions mais
également les suivis des grossesses
puisqu'il y a des grossesses forcées des
grossesses non désirées il y a aussi des
grossesses qui étaient désirées donc il
faut toujours englober le suivi des
femmes dans la totalité et pas
uniquement envoyer des chirurgiens qui
opère donc l'action de terrain c'est
être sur place c'est opéré mais ça ça a
une grande limite c'est quand vous venez
vous opérer ou déballer tout ce que vous
savez faire et puis au bout d'un mois
vous partez à J+1 le bénéfice il est
perdu si vous n'avez pas enseigné en
gros vous perdez la pérennité de ce que
vous faites donc il est quasiment plus
important d'enseigner ce que vous savez
faire que de faire ce que vous savez
faire
donc c'est de ça dont on va parler après
et puis ensuite je parlerai également de
la France parce que comme on le disait
c'est un peu
idiot en tout cas pas logique d'aller
très loin en Afrique pour essayer de
d'aider des femmes qui se font violer
elles font un parcours migratoire comme
le disait Morini Mercier tout à l'heure
et puis elles arrivent en France et puis
ils se font violer dans nos camps donc
là il y a un problème
[Musique]
et donc c'est la structure qui a été
créée bien sûr par le professeur
migougli lui-même et donc on y allait et
on entre autres on développait les
techniques la technique la seule dont je
voulais parler c'est une technique qui a
été validée par la Fédération
internationale de gynéco obstétrique en
2021 c'est une technique reproductive de
secure qui consiste à traiter par voie
basse des femmes qui souffrent de
prolapsus jeunes c'est à dire sur des
soit des séquelles handicapantes mais
aussi tout ce qui peut concerner des
violences sexuelles et des réparations
donc c'est surtout ça qu'on enseigne
entre autres donc pour tenir dans mes 10
minutes je vais pas représenter le
professeur muquier bon on le connaît
donc prix Nobel de la paix en 2018 et
c'est un homme qui a soigné plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de femmes depuis 20
ans dans son hôpital qui est échappé à 6
tentative d'assassinat et qui est
protégé par Monusco depuis
donc je vais vite voilà donc formation
création d'un diplôme universitaire de
schervaginal et pelvienne qui est devenu
périnéologie après donc depuis mai 2019
donc GSF avec Bernard crazy avec on crée
avec les experts congolais sur place et
le professeur de mes couilles un diplôme
universitaire qui validait directement
des jeunes africains généralistes
spécialistes étudiants pour un diplôme
reconnu par l'université évangélique
d'Afrique qui est très qui est une
grande valeur là bas et donc on a formé
en 2019 17 personnes qui savaient opérer
les femmes
avec bien sûr une formation à faire
après enfin en tout cas
comment dire une carrière voilà vous
avez une image justement de d'un
apprenti en train d'opérer derrière oui
tous les blancs qui sont en train de
superviser
et on enseigne directement c'est
vraiment du compagnonnage comme on le
fait chez nous c'est à dire attention
ici à la véniliaque etc il faut être
plus en dedans c'est vraiment c'est très
c'est du vrai compagnonnage c'est comme
ça qu'on apprend la chirurgie voilà la
dernière mission c'est tenue du 6 au 18
décembre 2021 alors pourquoi c'est si
loin parce que il y a eu le covid aussi
qui nous a un peu ralenti comme tout le
monde avec les quatre personnes que je
vous ai montré tout à l'heure donc le
matin on est au bloc on enseigne on a
des vrais patientes on dit voilà cette
sachant qu'on peut tout trouver sur des
violences sexuelles c'est pas comme les
mutilations traditionnelles où on a un
peu des catégories on peut trouver tout
et n'importe quoi c'est toujours un peu
une surprise et il peut y avoir de très
mauvaises surprises et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'on a étendu après
l'expertise enfin tout ce qui est et
urologique parce qu'il faut que ces
chirurgiens là soient capables de
prendre en charge des choses qui
n'existent pas jusque là
et puis l'après-midi donc formation en
théorique avec des cours qui sont
distribués sur l'anatomie sur la
chirurgie générale pour que ce soit un
véritable diplôme universitaire
voilà donc là on retrouve notre cher
professeur avec les quatre protagonistes
qui ont beaucoup travaillé œuvré pour
gynéco sans frontières
ça c'est juste pour montrer l'emploi du
temps on va passer dessus mais en gros
le matin vous avez le bloc l'après-midi
des cours et on a créé une véritable
reconnaissance du diplôme qui était
inaugurée depuis le 9 janvier 21
ou le président de panzzi était là qui
est un orthopédiste il y avait le doyen
de l'université on a fait ça en grande
pompe pour que les jeunes médecins qui
sortent de ce diplôme soit vraiment
reconnu et quelque chose entre les mains
et c'est important pour eux voilà donc
là vous allez le professeur qui fait un
cours l'après-midi donc c'est juste pour
que ce soit concret
juste un mot rapide sur ce que nous
faisons à outema alors
othéma c'est
ça a été monté c'est un petit hôpital
qui a été monté par Tony et Longuet qui
est un élève du professeur muquier qui
fait la même chose que lui c'est plus au
centre c'est plus safe mais on recueille
aussi des patientes qui évidemment fui
la zone Est qui viennent aussi atterrir
dans son hôpital et il a créé une
structure qui est très intéressante
parce qu'il opère mais aussi il leur
donne du travail elle peut rester elle
peut discuter entre elles il a créé un
lieu de vie elles sont pas obligées de
repartir après la chirurgie donc il les
réinsère complètement il y a un soutien
psychologique elle peut vous retrouver
une vie qu'elles ont perdu la plupart
pouvant être rejeté après avoir été
violé puisque c'est pas facile de
réintégrer une communauté elles peuvent
être complètement mises au banc de la
société parce qu'elles ont été violées
donc ça leur permet de trouver une
seconde vie
et nous sommes allés déjà sur faire une
mission là-bas de compagnonnage
chirurgicale du même acabit et nous
allons y retourner bien sûr en février
voilà c'est pour vous montrer des images
de l'hôpital de Thema
voilà là vous avez une photo on est en
train d'opérer voilà alors je termine je
sais pas où j'en suis mais je pense que
je suis en retard sur le parcours des
femmes issues de zone de conflit donc là
il arrive en France alors effectivement
il y a trois étapes dans les dans la
migration alors il y a le pays de départ
où ces femmes peuvent déjà avoir subi
des violences sexuelles il y a le
parcours elle peut en subir d'autres
c'est la loi des passeurs et il y a les
camps à l'arrivée ou c'est la loi du
plus fort et donc sur les trois étapes
ça prend pas la même forme mais au final
ça reste des violences sexuelles et il
faut prendre en compte l'ensemble du
parcours on peut intervenir
au départ c'est ce qu'on essaie de faire
au milieu c'est très difficile forcément
on essaie de les toucher et c'est pas
chez nous et si elles sont chez nous à
l'arrivée on a un devoir de les prendre
en charge et comme on le disait tout à
l'heure comme le disait madame Bardet
effectivement ce sont des des femmes qui
échappent en tout cas aux lignes qui
sont dessinées par les pouvoirs publics
et notamment dans les camps qui sont
créés un peu de façon illégale
pour d'autres raisons et le problème
c'est que la police n'y va pas forcément
et que la sécurité n'y est pas assurée
et évidemment ces femmes là sont les
premières cibles sont des fois dans une
tente au fond d'un camp enfin c'est
quelque chose
d'inaccessible et s'il y a des viols ou
en tout cas une pression pour des
services ou des passeurs on y a pas
accès
alors
là je vais pas trop m'attarder parce que
je suis en retard mais en gros la
condition féminine est complexe être un
homme c'est pas du tout pareil des
questions bêtes deviennent des questions
vitales comment uriner comment gérer ses
règles comment se laver comment laver
son enfant et puis qu'est-ce qu'on fait
si on a un enfant et qu'on subit une
pression sur lui d'un homme qui veut des
services sexuels ça c'est des questions
auxquelles elle ne peuvent pas répondre
et on a créé kaminor dans cette optique
là en 2015 sur l'appel d'Alexandra duth
comme je vous le disais qui est
sage-femme dans le Nord et on a créé à
peu près 150 missions depuis cette date
et surtout il y a eu kaminor au début
maintenant il y a Camille France à Paris
on a accueilli des femmes ukrainiennes
d'ailleurs on en a dans le sud on a à
Lyon enfin on s'est rendu compte qu'il y
avait des familles grandes partout en
France c'est pas uniquement dans le Nord
pour l'Angleterre
voilà donc ça consiste en gros à faire
des maraudes ce qu'il faut aller les
chercher ces femmes très souvent elles
viennent pas se présenter dire j'ai des
soucis on a même dû cacher l'estampis
GSF sur notre camion parce que on
voulait pas enfin on s'est rendu compte
que quand elle rentrait là les hommes ne
savaient pas trop ce qu'elles allaient
chercher et donc on a voulu rendre
silencieuse la consultation donc on est
on a tout effacé on a fait un camion
blanc comme MSF et on s'est rendu compte
que les femmes venaient plus si on
n'était pas on n'avait pas la signature
gynéco en les écoute on les prend en
charge évidemment les viols il y a toute
une logistique derrière de DST de
grossesse qu'il faut prendre en charge
qui est très lourde il y a pas
uniquement la réparation
l'accompagnement juridique etc on essaie
d'englober en travaillant avec d'autres
personnes
voilà donc ça c'est la photo de la fin
donc les enfants arrivent à être heureux
c'est l'essentiel
voilà
c'était bien résumé pour cette dernière
photo surtout pour votre intervention la
présentation de ces actions remarquables
diverses
je vais maintenant donner la parole à
biotech sans frontière en lui demandant
de bien vouloir excuser la manière dont
j'ai peut-être mal prononcé son nom tout
à l'heure donc dans les paroles à Madame
Michel qui pêche en espérant cette fois
je n'ai pas avoir estropié votre nom
absolument pas merci beaucoup monsieur
le sénateur madame la Présidente
messieurs mesdames et sénateurs mesdames
messieurs pour pour cette opportunité de
vous présenter nos actions est-ce que je
peux vous demander docteur charbonnier
de récupérer le
la petite télécommande
merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup pour pour ces échanges
extrêmement intéressants pour nous
peut-être que je vais me permettre de
faire un petit pas de côté pour vous
parler du mandat de bibliothèque en
frontières avant de rentrer dans le vif
du sujet justement pour vous expliquer
en quoi ces espaces communautaires ces
espaces de sociabilité peuvent aussi
devenir des espaces sécurisés pour la
prise en charge des femmes et plus
globalement des victimes de violences
sexuelles dans les conflits
Bibliothèques Sans Frontières est une
ONG qui a été créé il y a maintenant 15
ans avec le mandat de faciliter l'accès
et l'accessibilité à la connaissance
partout dans le monde et notamment
auprès des populations les plus
vulnérables je vais je vais m'en
remettre aux interventions de de mes
prédécesseurs et notamment Céline Bardet
du docteur Charbonnet pour pour vous
expliquer en quoi ces bibliothèques
peuvent aussi être des lieux
d'émancipation des lieux de prise en
charge psychologique je vais revenir sur
trois aspects qui me semblent assez
primordiaux le premier c'est cette
notion de l'allée vert en anglais on dit
outreach cette notion d'aller au plus
près des populations qui ont besoin d'un
accompagnement qui ont besoin d'aide
humanitaire qui ont besoin d'un soutien
psychologique parce qu'effectivement
quand on est victime venir chercher
cette aide
pour venir chercher sa tête on va être
confronté à une multitude de barrières
des barrières sociales des barrières
psychologiques des barrières symboliques
aussi qui nous empêchent d'aller vers
les personnes qui proposent cette aide
et simplement pour les acteurs
humanitaires de les identifier la
question de la temporalité aussi est
extrêmement importante la temporalité de
la prise en charge immédiate
urgente mais aussi celle de la
reconstruction et celle de la
possibilité de se projeter dans un
avenir à nouveau et cela pour les
victimes de violences sexuelles mais
aussi pour leur entourage pour les
enfants pour tous ceux qui ont été
potentiellement traumatisés par ces
violences même s'ils ne les ont pas subi
directement et enfin une notion qui nous
touche beaucoup c'est celle de la
capacité d'agir on a entendu parler tout
à l'heure d'un paravent les femmes
victimes de violences sexuelles sont
souvent mises à l'écart sauf souvent
ostracisés stigmatisé et la nécessité
pour elle de pouvoir se reconstruire de
reconstruire leur dignité mais aussi de
pouvoir avoir accès à des moyens de
subsistance de pouvoir s'autonomiser
financièrement et socialement cet enjeu
est tout aussi primordial à la lutte
contre les violences sexuelles dans les
conflits
le docteur charbonnier parlait tout à
l'heure des catastrophes naturelles vous
avez une signe photo de du camp de
déplacer à Port-au-Prince à Haïti après
le tremblement de terre c'est je vous
montre cette photo parce qu'en réalité
c'est ce qu'il y a présidé le le
premier interventions dans une situation
humanitaire à bibliothèque sans
frontières on travaillait Haïti auprès
des bibliothécaires et des universités
locales pour construire justement un
réseau d'accès à la connaissance partout
dans le pays le tremblement de terre a
eu lieu le texte en frontières est
rentré en France en se disant qu'on
n'était pas une ONG humanitaire et qu'il
y avait d'autres besoins qui étaient
primordiaux les questions de santé
d'accès au logement d'accès aux soins
d'accès à des vêtements simplement à de
la nourriture et en réalité ce sont nos
partenaires Haïtiens qui nous ont
rappelés au bout de deux semaines en
nous disant ce que vous faisiez
auparavant avant le tremblement de terre
est encore plus primordial maintenant
parce que dans un camp de déplacé il y a
des rumeurs qui circulent l'accès à
l'information devient extrêmement
difficile la protection des populations
les plus vulnérables les femmes les
enfants devient encore plus difficile ce
sont les premières victimes des
violences et les ONG peinent à toucher
ces populations et donc nous sommes
retournés à Haïti aux côtés d'Unicef et
nous avons créé ce qu'on a appelé des
bibliothèques soustences simplement qui
était tout bêtement des espaces d'accès
à la culture d'accès à l'éducation
d'accès à l'information au camp au sein
des camps de déplacées vous voyez ici
une bibliothèque sous tente et vous
voyez ce tableau ce tableau noir dont on
voit l'envers en réalité les
humanitaires s'en sont servis comme un
point d'information pour le reste de la
population pour le camp parce que en
créant ce lien humain avec les
populations déplacées les
bibliothécaires les volontaires ont créé
un lien de confiance qui faisait que les
humanitaires étaient en capacité de
diffuser de l'information vérifier
auprès des populations déplacées et donc
très vite ces lieux sont non seulement
devenus des lieux éducatifs de prise en
charge des populations mais sont aussi
devenues des lieux sécurisés pour les
personnes déplacées des lieux où ils
savaient que l'information qui allait
lui être distribué serait fiable serait
vérifié
nous sommes allés voir le Haut
Commissariat au réfugiés après cette
invention en Haïti en nous rendant
compte à quel point la dimension
intellectuelle de l'être humain était
peu prise en compte dans les guidelines
d'intervention humanitaire le HR a été
extrêmement
touché par cette par cette
interpellation mais nous a dit tant que
votre intervention ne rentrera pas dans
les standards humanitaires tant qu'elles
ne sera pas facilement déployable sur
les terrains reconnaître ce droit à
l'accès à la connaissance sera une
gageure sera forcément compliqué et donc
nous avons dans ce contexte-là crée cet
outil avec le HR avec le designer
Philippe star qui a travaillé pro bono
avec nous qui s'appelle l'idéalbox
c'est ce que vous voyez ici ce sont des
modules des fly caisses comme on en
utilise pour transporter les instruments
de musique en tournée qui tiennent sur
deux palettes et quand on le déploie ça
crée un espace d'une centaine de mètres
carrés qui contient l'équivalent
finalement d'une petite bibliothèque on
va y retrouver des livres papier
évidemment mais on va aussi retrouver un
accès à Internet on va y retrouver
trouver un serveur qui permet d'accéder
à des milliers de contenus sans
connexion internet parce que souvent on
en est des contextes où l'accès à la
connectivité est compliqué soit parce
qu'elle est trop chère soit parce que
l'infrastructure n'existe pas ou tout
simplement parce que c'est censuré on va
y retrouver aussi de quoi créer soi-même
du contenu et on y reviendra mais c'est
extrêmement important de faire entendre
la voix des réfugiés la voix des
populations déplacée par elle-même donc
ces idiots box aujourd'hui on en a
déployé près de 150 dans le monde on
compte à peu près un million de visites
tous les ans au sein des IOS box avec
des populations très très diverses vous
voyez ici quelques photos de la diodebox
déployées dans des centres d'accueil de
réfugiés en Europe aux frontières de
l'Ukraine où on a travaillé tout de
suite après le conflit le début du
conflit pardon en Colombie vous voyez
des IOS box qui ont été déployés dans
les zones de démobilisation des expars
et le partenariat avec l'ONU que
mentionné monsieur le sénateur est né
justement de la visite d'une de ses iOS
box en Pologne aux frontières de
l'Ukraine par la Représentante spéciale
du Secrétaire général des Nations Unies
sur les violences faites aux femmes dans
les conflits
elle est venue nous voir en nous disant
mais en réalité ces espaces sont des
espaces qui sont extrêmement
intéressants parce que ils permettent de
façon quasi anonyme d'aller toucher des
personnes qui ne viendraient pas
forcément vers les ONG qui leur
apportent de l'aide médicale un soutien
psychologique elle a qualifié ces box de
d'un mot un peu un peu un peu naïf mais
extrêmement parlant de magicalboxes pour
elle c'était des endroits un peu
magiques où les personnes étaient en
capacité de renouer avec un sens de
normalité avec finalement une dignité
humaine qui avait été mise à mal par les
violences qu'elles ont subies vous voyez
une signe une carte de 19 contextes
surveillés par les Nations Unies alors
on le disait tout à l'heure évidemment
dans toute situation de conflit il y en
réalité des violences sexuelles et le
viol l'utilisait comme arme de guerre
néanmoins c'est extrêmement compliqué
d'avoir des informations vérifiées de
recueillir des témoignages et donc ici
vous voyez les 19 contextes qui sont
surveillés par l'ONU parce que des
témoignages vérifiés ils ont été
collectés
nous lançons ce partenariat tout juste
cette année avec la volonté de pouvoir
travailler sur trois aspects de la prise
en charge des femmes victimes de
violence la première c'est une approche
holistique qui permettra de prendre en
charge de façon globale les femmes et
leur entourage victime des violences
sexuelles s'agit de créer des espaces
sécurisés grâce au déploiement de ses
adios box dans des situations de
conflits pour pouvoir y proposer une
prise en charge psychologique et sociale
par des experts du sujet pouvoir y
recueillir des témoignages de façon
sécurisée proposée de stocker des
documents juridiques pour permettre à
ces femmes quand elles seront prêtes de
pouvoir porter plainte mais aussi de
travailler sur la question de la
capacité d'agir à travers des activités
éducatives du renforcement de
compétences de la formation
professionnelle
s'agit aussi de leur donner les moyens
de pouvoir entreprendre et aussi de
pouvoir prendre en charge les enfants
victimes elles aussi de violences
collatérales ou de communion directe ça
c'est l'approche au niveau des victimes
de violences sexuelles les premiers
déploiements à l'étude pour 2023 vont
avoir lieu vraisemblablement en Ukraine
en Afghanistan et en RDC dans le Kivu
je me dépêche car le temps passe et
enfin deux autres aspects qui ne
semblent tout aussi importants c'est
premièrement la formation des
professionnels de terrain à pouvoir
identifier prendre en charge toutes les
composantes de toutes les composantes de
soins des victimes de violences
sexuelles dans les conflits donc c'est
pouvoir accompagner des professionnels
de santé des infirmières des médecins
qui ne sont pas forcément spécialisés
des questions de gynécologie ni des
questions de soutien psychologiques aux
victimes et pouvoir leur donner les
éléments pour identifier les victimes
pour pouvoir les accompagner les
diagnostiquer et ensuite les référés à
des experts en capacité de les
accompagner durablement mais c'est aussi
faire de la prévention et donc former
les acteurs de terrain les forces armées
les populations qui côtoient les
populations déplacées qui côtoient les
victimes
comme on le disait tout à l'heure cette
notion de prévention extrêmement
compliquée mais en même temps
extrêmement primordial pour avoir une
approche qui soit la plus complète
possible qui partent de la gestion avant
conflit et qui prennent en charge les
femmes de façon durable je vais
m'arrêter ici et je vous remercie de
votre attention et de ces échanges
extrêmement intéressants
de tes actions menées par BSF et leur
grande diversité alors je vous propose
de donner la parole à notre dernier
intervenant de cette deuxième table
ronde madame Masika bilamba qui
intervient en visioconférence depuis et
cela fonctionne depuis la République
démocratique du Congo qui préside de
l'ONG synergie des femmes pour des
victimes de violences sexuelles madame
vous avez la parole
il faudrait le son avant l'image
en images mais pas le sort madame ne
vous entend pas
c'était trop beau
est-ce que vous avez activer votre micro
vous entendez pas non plus
on va tenter une seconde fois j'imagine
puisque si ça a été coupé
quand il y a juste le son qui manque
c'est quand même dommage vraiment parce
que c'est une théoriquement juste un
clic et moi qui est pas des compétences
est-ce qu'on vous entend non toujours
pas
est-ce qu'il y a quelqu'un à côté de
vous qui pourrait vous aider à connecter
le son
où est-ce que le son est mis
suffisamment fort après ça peut être
juste ça finalement
votre micro semble couper en haut non
c'est vidéo direct non
lorsque vous êtes connecté madame est-ce
que vous avez activé le micro
nous avons tous fait des progrès
pendant le confinement sur la maîtrise
de la technologie surtout moi mais
parfois c'est
est-ce que la technique au dessus de moi
peut
nous dire ce qui se passe voilà
ça me paraît compliqué
donc vous allez dans les paramètres sur
le côté il y a des petits points
votre micro est allumé depuis chez nous
est-ce que vous parlez madame
non vous entend pas toujours pas
mais de notre côté votre micro est
allumé c'est qu'il n'est pas connecté de
votre côté
vous avez un item avec une caméra et un
item avec un micro
elle tente de reconnecter on fait une
dernière tentative
est-ce que c'est bon madame
et ben non
alors écoutez je ne sais pas on va
peut-être max notre collègue Max Brisson
va peut-être prendre une question on
fera une tentative juste après et puis
sinon on passera la troisième table
ronde nous sommes en direct et il faut
donc essayer de vous adapter essayez de
tout éteindre madame pendant une
question vous éteignez tout et lorsque
vous vous connectez vous activez wifi
vidéo micro surtout la totalité même si
vous nous coupez en plein milieu de
notre déroulé on arrivera probablement à
se connecter vous acceptez tout la visio
le micro tout notre président tu es
prête à prendre aussi la présidence du
groupe numérique je peux prendre un
avion et aller me connecter mais il y a
même un sapin de Noël chez vous en plus
alors écoutez
allez je je laisse max et remplacement
prendre une question en attendant des
questions pour nos madame j'espère
collègues
[Musique]
avec toi
merci beaucoup j'ai un collègue il y a
pas de souci oui
j'ai vraiment apprécié d'entendre tout
ce que j'ai entendu mais en même temps
c'est très difficile ce sont des choses
très très difficiles que vivent toutes
ces femmes qui sont sur des de guerre et
franchement c'est courageux de la part
de toutes celles qui résistent et qui
permettent qu'on soit informé de ce qui
se passe également et les
ONG là docteur j'ai une question pour
vous alors vous avez parlé de la
chirurgie la réparation nous avons eu au
sein de la délégation
auditionnée également le professeur
kingge qui était venu à une de nos
réunions et je voudrais savoir qu'en
est-il de la prévention par exemple en
fait bon pas je sais même pas si
prévention mais concernant les les
maladies sexuellement transmis
parce qu'il y a éventuellement aussi des
situations où il y a des transmissions
de
certains virus ou d'autres choses des
bactéries donc est-ce que c'est possible
de prendre en charge comment vous faites
parce que vous êtes dans les conditions
particulièrement compliquées difficiles
alors est-ce que c'est pris en compte
également
on va peut-être prendre plusieurs
questions à moins qu'on ait le lien avec
la République du Congo non toujours pas
cette infrastru se poser alors en tant
que après la question de victoire
j'espère matin je crois que vous aviez
souhaité pour la parole
pour
vous Thomas est-ce que quand vous quand
votre organisation en fait international
victime est-ce que par exemple vous
délivrez des certificats etc j'avais
cette question là et l'autre elle était
pour BSF c'est que moi j'ai pas fait de
présentation backup je vois que tout le
monde a fait une présentation j'aurais
pu mais je voulais savoir quand on parle
de coffre-fort juridique dans votre
projet de quoi on parle exactement parce
que
c'est mes deux questions merci et enfin
je vois bien oui moi c'était une
question sur la prévention puisqu'on
sait qu'il y a beaucoup de mariage
précoce en Afrique on sait aussi que
beaucoup de femmes parce qu'elles sont
violées au sein même du mariage et
souvent très jeune on est conséquences
gynécologiques extrêmement graves et
sont renvoyés parce qu'il y a un
problème en fait c'est un médecin
d'ambassade qui m'avait expliqué ça des
problèmes d'odeurs qui sont censés être
extrêmement gênantes et refusé par la
famille et elle se retrouve en errant
sur les routes est-ce que vous
travaillez aussi sur cette question là
en matière de prévention pour essayer de
limiter ces unions précoces et question
subsidiaires est-ce que vous avez une
aide suffisante de nos ambassades
françaises à l'étranger merci
donc allez-y
merci beaucoup bonjour marie-lucier je
travaille pour Médecin du Monde et je
vais compléter un petit peu avec les
questions sur ce que vous proposez et un
peu les problématiques que vous
rencontrez nous ce qu'on voit aussi sur
sur ces terrains c'est très universel
mais dans ces cas-là la demande et le
besoin est assez immédiat c'est sur les
grossesses non désirées et la question
des avortements donc je vous pose cette
question sur les contextes dans lesquels
vous intervenez comment vous abordez
cette question là et quelle réponse vous
pouvez apporter
je vais déjà répondre à votre question
parce que madame est partie une seconde
alors pour tout ce qui est
avortement suite de grossesse aussi y
compris les grossesses non désirées
effectivement c'est une grosse
problématique que nous prenons en charge
puisque le droit à l'avortement doit
être accessible en particulier dans nos
camps donc on chez nous on utilise la
passe donc ça on sait faire et on le
prend en considération dans les pays où
nous allons si ce pays l'autorise parce
qu'il faut faire attention aussi on
n'est pas chez nous et donc on se plie
toujours à la politique locale et tant
que c'est possible évidemment on y donne
accès on sait comment faire surtout si
on a une antenne chirurgicale donc on
prend compte l'IVG à 100% si c'est
désiré tout en gardant des parcours
discrets évidemment pour éviter que ça
ne se sache trop
[Musique]
d'accord la deuxième question c'était
sur la prévention des IST alors
évidemment c'est un très très gros
problème et le problème de la prévention
ou du de la cure de list c'est surtout
toucher la femme en question déjà
qu'elles sont en consultation qu'elle
soit dans le centre et qu'elle soit pas
reclus dans un camp quelque part donc ça
c'est ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure la
plus grosse étape c'est évidemment
d'arriver à soigner cette femme alors
sur le sur les IST le professeur muquier
avait insisté d'ailleurs il avait fait
un article dans Le Monde là-dessus en
disant que c'était un gros problème
d'ailleurs des violences sexuelles dans
les suites et comme il le précisait
c'est un crime qui s'inscrit dans la
durée et l'iester et parfois même un
objectif comme c'était le cas Rwanda
dans sa transmission et forcément on est
très inquiet là-dessus alors certaines
sont faciles à soigner comme des
syphilis on met des antibiots mais
d'autres forcément vont impliquer un
suivi à vie et c'est toujours un
problème de suivre ces femmes et en
général l'ISTP pour elle c'est le
dernier de ses soucis mais on le prend
évidemment en compte
en plus j'ai une grossesse qui peut se
rajouter enfin nous on va aller la
chercher mais c'est pas sa première
demande en général effectivement on s'en
occupe sur les hépatites entre autres
aussi et puis alors la question de
certificat c'était au chirurgien que
nous formons alors oui sur le du
justement ah non pardon pardon
c'était quand vous retrouvez à traiter
des personnes à traiter des victimes
est-ce que vous établissez des
certificats est-ce que c'est quelque
chose qu'une est-ce qu'une victime elle
peut avoir juridique
non on est oui exactement alors si c'est
par contre si c'est en France oui bien
sûr là on va rejoindre tous les parcours
logos possible il faut que les patientes
puissent porter plainte enfin on va
vraiment on traite cette personne
comment traiterait n'importe quelle
personne de notre nationalité après sur
les sur les camps de en Afrique à
hautema le certificat aura pas de valeur
il peut en avoir une mais il sera pas
reconnu en tant que tel il faut qu'il
soit fait par les autorités locales et
souvent ils n'y vont pas on a en tout
cas nous ONG on ne le fait pas mais
effectivement il faut que ce soit fait
dans le pays et bien d'accord mais nous
on ne le fait pas pour c'est pas sur
place ce qu'on appelle légitimité en
tant qu'étranger quoi c'est ça le truc
alors on m'indique que le son est
rétabli
mais l'information
qui vient de la Présidente je le précise
ça c'est facile quand ça marche
c'est moi quand ça marche pas c'est les
autres je fais ça également très souvent
en fait j'essaye de remplir le temps
mais si si ça va je pense qu'on m'a dit
que ça fonctionnait donc voilà oui mais
c'est toi
ok merci beaucoup monsieur le sénateur
merci madame la Présidente
merci
c'est pour moi un grand honneur le
problème est que moi je n'écoute plus
donc moi
alors vous nous entendez pas c'est
normal mais on vous écoute madame
ok merci je disais que
et je vous parle à partir de Goma et
vous avez vu le problème technique que
nous rencontrons et je voulais seulement
dire que notre province du Nord qui vous
partagez la frontière avec deux pays le
Rwanda et l'Ouganda comme vous les
connaissez également il y a les combats
qui ont repris ce jour ici et la guerre
est juste à la porte de la ville de Goma
et c'est ce qui a fait que je ne suis
pas avec vous aujourd'hui donc c'est
depuis le mois de mai que les combats
ont repris entre les rebelles du M23 et
les forces armées du Congo et qui ont
causé des déplacements massifs des
populations ils ont ils ont coupé la
route nationale numéro 2 qui
approvisionne la ville de Goma en vivre
et qui fait la connexion avec les deux
provinces la province du Nord qui vous
est la province de l'itori et qui permet
aussi les trafic entre la RDC et Lugana
la province du Nord qui vous aujourd'hui
a environ
280 milles déplacés internes mais les
nombres continuent à s'accroître puisque
hier il y avait encore des affrontements
entre la RDC et
entre les rebelles bien 23 et les forces
de la République démocratique du Congo
et là les déplacer vivent dans des
conditions inhumaines des camps de
fortune sous la pluie comme nous sommes
dans la saison pluvieuse et sous le
menaces incessantes des combats et des
maladies à base hydriques puisque
notamment le choléra puisque les
conditions ne sont pas réunies il y a
aussi des
qui était sur terrain ils parlent déjà
de plus des d'une dizaine de personnes
qui ont décédé suite peut-être des
maladies suite à la fatigue ou suite à
des conditions qui ne sont pas humaines
on m'a demandé de parler de la
réparation mais je ne peux pas faire je
peux pas le faire avant de faire mon
plaidoyer pour la femme la paix pour les
femmes il faut que les femmes paient et
sécurité et actions humanitaires qui est
les fonds pour les femmes actions et
humanitaires
femme paix et sécurité et actions
humanitaires que les organisations
féminines de la province du Nord qui
vous puissent bénéficier de ses fonds
car ces rapports a été adopté par
l'Assemblée générale des Nations Unies
en les 12 septembre 2002
nous venons de fêter le 22 ans de la
résolution femme et sécurité qui peut
qui parlent de la place qu'occupe les
femmes dans la résolution des conflits
comme vous le savez ma province ça fait
plus de
décennies qui nous sont mangués il y a
des enfants qui sont nés et qui n'ont
jamais connu la paix les enfants qui
sont à l'est de la République
démocratique du Congo pour parler de la
réparation je me demande moi-même
souvent par où prendre le problème
car il faut réparer mais je me pose la
question
pour réparer les corps alors
tous les deux ans au niveau
un nouveau pic des violences vient
menacer sévèrement les populations
que les femmes risquent leur vie au
quotidien en Allah
simplement chercher de l'eau ou en
allant chercher à manger et sur les
routes
parler des esprits
alors que nous sommes dans un état de
survie et des chocs depuis plus de deux
décennies
c'est toute une génération qui n'a
jamais connu la paix comme j'ai parlé
des enfants les enfants qui ont 20 ans
aujourd'hui ils n'ont jamais eu la
chance de passer la nuit dans une maison
ils doivent se déplacer quotidiennement
dans des cas des fortunes pour protéger
leur vie
réparer les armes alors que la violence
et la mort attendent nos enfants au
retour au détour d'une forêt où il y a
possibilité de résilience quand tous les
efforts de réparations peuvent
s'effondrer à quelques heures
prépare les institutions
gangrener
par la corruption ou la soif du pouvoir
soutenir par l'air détournement par des
pratiques et d'industrie internationales
qui ferment les yeux voir finance des
pratiques qui desservent nos sociétés
pour le profit individuel
il est parfois difficile de croire aux
possibilités des réparations
mais je voudrais évoquer ici deux points
la prise en charge et l'indoniste et
l'indemnisation des victimes pour la
prise en charge globale des victimes de
violences sexuelles je crois que mes
prédécesseurs ont beaucoup parlé de la
République dans le pratique du Congo et
surtout des la province du Nord qui vous
d'où je viens je crois que moi je veux
parler un peu de l'indemnisation qui
reste un grand défi dans
l'accompagnement des victimes des
violences sexuelles il est vrai que
lorsque il y a eu des fonds au profit
des victimes nous avions cru et nous
avons que ça sera un ouf des soulagement
pour les victimes mais aujourd'hui après
le projet pilote par les fonds établis
par le docteur mokorige Nadia Mourad là
aussi les victimes d'autres provinces
n'ont pas bénéficier de ce projet
pilotes donc ça reste le même problème
que ça soit du côté du gouvernement
où nous attendons la loi pour que les
fonds soient opérationnel ça traîne donc
nous n'avons pas toujours de solutions
de ces de ses côtés là
vous auriez encore compris malgré les
progrès nous ne pourrons pas parler
de se rendre de
nous ne pouvons pas parler des
réparations de victimes de violences
sexuelles puisque il y a beaucoup de
choses il y a pas la paix moi je crois
que nous devons parler de la réparation
lorsque il y a la paix mais cependant
j'ai une question à vous poser
combien d'entre vous avez vous d'enfants
ici et combien peuvent nous aider
puisque nous ne pouvons pas faire la
réparation sa votre aide je sais qu'il y
a parmi nous beaucoup qui vont répondre
activement oui nous nous allons vous
aider mais moi
je sais que votre réponse je vais
demander que votre réponse attendait
puisque ce sont vos actes tout au long
de notre parcours qui vont nous soutenir
qui vont montrer que vous que vous
voulez nous soutenir je vous remercie
merci Madame pour votre témoignage pour
votre appel aussi est-ce qu'il suscite
des réactions de la salle ou des
intervenants ici en tribune
à la troisième table ronde merci
chaleureusement je dis au revoir à une
mère de Vendée qui s'en va en même temps
au revoir Anne merci Monsieur le
lundi matin de cette table ronde de
chers collègues Max Brisson Merci à VOUS
docteur mesdames pour toutes ces
précisions et nous allons entamer notre
troisième table ronde avec vous voyez on
voyage beaucoup c'est la chambre des
territoires le Seda nous avons eu le
nord nous avons eu les
Pyrénées-Atlantiques avec
Martine filleul et Max Brisson et
maintenant nous passons en Haute-Savoie
avec notre collègue Loïc Hervé qui va
animer cette troisième table ronde et
dernière table ronde avec évidemment
un sujet un sujet différent évidemment
les femmes engagées dans les conflit
armée contemporains et les enjeux
actuels de mixité des armées c'est vrai
que on a parlé beaucoup au cours des
deux premières tables rondes des femmes
victimes des femmes armes de guerre mais
il y a aussi des femmes engagées dans
les territoires et dans les pays en
guerre et et je vais vous raconter une
anecdote en
pendant que vous vous installez c'est
vrai que au moment de cette grave
invasion russe de l'Ukraine il y avait
une campagne électorale et la manière
dont
cette invasion était traitée et la
manière dont on parlait de des femmes
victimes et non pas des femmes aussi
actrices me faisait croire que nous
n'étions pas prêts la société française
n'était peut-être pas encore prête à
voter pour quel que soit l'appartenance
apporter au plus haut niveau de l'État
une femme présidente puisqu'on parlait
toujours des femmes victimes qui
venaient se protéger et non pas des
femmes engagées dans les territoires or
il y a de nombreux territoires où les
femmes aussi sont engagées donc je sais
d'immédiatement la parole à notre
collègue Loïc Hervé qui va animer cette
troisième et dernière table ronde je
vous remercie
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues madame messieurs je souhaite
ouvrir cette troisième partie de nos
travaux pour parler des femmes engagées
dans les conflits armées contemporains
des enjeux actuels de mixité dans les
armées en souhaitant la bienvenue aux
quatre participantes ces dernières
séquences Madame Catherine bourdès
commissaire général haute fonctionnaire
à l'égalité des droits du ministère des
armées
commandant claire vous êtes officier de
l'Armée de l'Air et de l'Espace je
rappelle aux personnes qui participent
que selon les dispositions actuellement
en vigueur dans les armées on ne citera
que votre prénom
madame ANAC vite sociologue ukrainienne
membre du projet invisible bataillon qui
documente la participation des femmes
ukrainiennes aux actions militaires
depuis 2015 et Son Excellence Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur de France en Ukraine
Etienne de Poncin qui nous fait
également l'honneur d'être parmi nous en
visioconférence
depuis que ce matin
l'objet de cette troisième et dernière
séquence est de se pencher sur la place
des femmes dans les conflits armés
contemporains celle qui sont notamment
engagées dans les unités opérationnelles
de combat
historiquement si les femmes ont
toujours joué leur part dans la défense
de leur pays on pense notamment aux
résistantes elles sont
traditionnellement peu présentes dans
les corps armés cependant cette
situation évolue de manière
significative et notamment dans notre
pays
la professionnalisation des armées en
France en 1996 a donné une impulsion
décisive à l'armée à l'arrivée massive
de femmes au sein des Forces Françaises
notre armée d'aujourd'hui l'une des plus
féminisées au monde avec 15% de femmes
parmi ces militaires et environ 10%
parmi les officiers aujourd'hui toutes
les fonctions au sein des armées sont
accessibles aux femmes
le dernier verrou est en celui de
l'accès au sous-marin ayant sauté en
2014 et j'ai moi-même je suis
actuellement auditeur à l'ihdn et nous
étions à Brest la semaine dernière
c'était notamment un des sujets que nous
avons abordés avec les
l'amiral et les commandants des des
sous-marins du carlosant que nous avons
visité puisque c'est maintenant quelque
chose qui est tout à fait tout à fait
possible pour autant elles ne sont pas
présentes au même niveau dans toutes les
composantes dans chacune des armes
services et fonctions associées l'armée
de l'air est aujourd'hui la plus
féminisée avec près d'un quart de femme
comme on dort j'imagine que vous nous en
parlerez de la même manière la
répartition des femmes au sein des
différentes catégories affichent des
disparités importantes en 2018 seul
10,4% des femmes militaires étaient
officiers
41,5% sous-officiers et 47,7% restants
étaient des militaires du rang
enfin les femmes étaient souvent sous
représentées dans les fonctions
opérationnelles et combattantes en 2013
Françoise Godin alors haute
fonctionnaire à l'égalité au ministère
de la Défense évoquait devant notre
délégation plusieurs axes de progression
de la féminisation de l'armée française
renforcement de l'encadrement féminin
dans les écoles militaires constitution
d'un vivier de recrutement de femmes
investies de haute responsabilités mis
en oeuvre d'une réflexion sur l'accès
des femmes aux formations militaires
école de guerre et diplôme d'état-major
c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
indispensable pour parvenir au cursus de
haut niveau et enfin la mise en place
d'un observatoire de la parité à la
défense
le 18 septembre 2018 madame la ministre
Florence Parly avait également affirmé
devant le réseau avec les femmes de la
défense ouvrez les guillemets je veux
que le féminin de général ne soit plus
femme de général et je souhaite que
chacun ait sa place et puisse donner
l'exemple je souhaite également
atteindre le niveau de 10% d'officier
généraux féminins d'ici 2022 fin de
citation Madame la Commissaire général
et haute fonctionnaires à l'égalité des
droits au ministère des armées chère
Madame et Catherine bourdès vous nous
direz où nous en sommes aujourd'hui sur
ces différents sujets si vous voulez
bien commandant vous êtes officier de
l'Armée de l'Air et de l'Espace vous
avez effectué des opérations extérieures
notamment sur la base aérienne de Niamey
au profit de l'opération Barka
vous pourrez nous faire part des raisons
qui ont motivé votre choix de vous
engager dans l'Armée de l'Air et de
l'Espace et éventuellement des
contraintes de cet engagement peut-être
celle que vous ressentez plus en tant
que femme qu'en tant qu'officier si tel
est bien le cas bien entendu vous
occupez aujourd'hui un poste de
commandement considérez-vous que les
étapes à franchir pour y parvenir ont
été plus difficiles pour vous que pour
vos comètes que vos collègues masculins
mais enfin sur le plan international on
a beaucoup parlé de l'engagement des
femmes kurdes contre daesh en Syrie et
en Irak mais aussi de celui des femmes
ukrainiennes dans les unités de combat
de l'armée ukrainienne ou dans les
fonctions de soutien des minages qu'on
lui de véhicules soutien logistique
notre référent de ce matin est aussi
l'occasion de les mettre à l'honneur
un acte vite nous éclaira notamment sur
le rôle des femmes qui constituent près
de 20% des forces de combat
ukrainiennes et nous livrera également
une analyse sur l'évolution de la place
des femmes dans cette armée qui en
réalité est à l'oeuvre depuis le début
du conflit dans l'est du l'Ukraine
depuis 2014 et pour clore cette séquence
notre ambassadeur de France en Ukraine
monsieur Étienne de Poncin pourra depuis
la capitale ukrainienne faire un état
des lieux de l'engagement des femmes
ukrainiennes sur le terrain dans le
cadre du conflit armé entre la Russie et
l'Ukraine et dans sa dimension
opérationnelle je laisse donc sans plus
tarder la parole à Madame la Commissaire
général Catherine bourdès haute
fonctionnaire à l'égalité des droits au
ministère des armées de la parole merci
monsieur le sénateur et et merci de nous
accueillir dans ce lieu magnifique et
surtout merci
de nous permettre de parler de cette
question qui tient beaucoup à coeur au
mystère des armées je voudrais juste
dire un mot à Madame billon que je
remercie de signaler que les femmes ne
sont pas que des victimes et je suis
très heureuse que cette table ronde nous
permet justement d'en parler comme vous
le savez nous sommes aussi actrice de la
lutte contre les violences et ça a été
dit dans la table ronde précédente et je
vous retrouve ça vraiment très bien
parce que nous sommes aussi des
guerrières il faut le dire et nous
sommes aussi là pour résoudre les
conflits et c'est là où on rejoint la
première intervenante qui a parlé de la
résolution du Conseil de l'ONU la 13-25
sur la contribution des femmes à la
résolution des comptes conflits il est
essentiel que nous y soyons voilà et
pour qu'on y soit et bien il faut aussi
qu'on soit dans les armées qui vont
porter cette solution sur le terrain et
donc il faut que les armées occidentales
qui sont grosses parties des batillants
de l'ONU mais bon pas uniquement bien
entendu mais il faut que donc tous ces
toutes ces toutes ces armées est composé
de femmes et des femmes bons niveaux
pour que la culture de la mixité soit
suffisamment imprégnée pour que sur le
terrain dans des conditions extrêmement
difficiles on soit capable de
l'appliquer quand même voilà donc
c'était une petite incise donc pour ce
qui concerne la place des femmes dans
les armées
françaises dont je vous parlerai surtout
des Françaises même si j'ai une bonne
idée de ce qui se passe chez mes alliés
puisque chez nos alliés je suis en
contact quotidien avec eux il faut
savoir qu'on a tous en Europe dans
l'OTAN bénéficier de tous les efforts
qui ont été déployés dans la société
civile nous sommes le reflet de notre
société et tout ce qui a été fait en
faveur de l'égalité professionnelle du
droit des femmes etc a eu des
répercussions chez nous
voilà donc cette question voilà vous
avez cité des des dates assez récentes
je pense qu'il faut quand même juste
noter une date 1972 c'est l'année où les
hommes et les femmes ont eu un statut
unique dans les armées jusqu'à présent
nous étions égaux mais séparés avec
voilà nous étions que les femmes et en
72 un seul statut les femmes ont les
mêmes règles ce qui s'applique la même
sol les mêmes obligations les mêmes
droits donc ça c'est le moment fondateur
de voilà de la vraie féminisation des
armées après depuis 50 ans il y a eu
beaucoup d'autres voilà il y a beaucoup
d'autres États
l'ouverture des femmes aux femmes des
écoles d'officiers puisque ça s'est
étalé entre 77 et 93 il y a eu la
suppression des quotas puisque avant il
y avait non pas des quotas pour faire
entrer des femmes et des quotas pour les
exclure quand je suis entrée dans
l'armée de l'air puisque j'ai un premier
cursus dans l'armée de l'air nous étions
trois femmes pour 120 élèves à
Salon-de-Provence et il trouvait déjà
que ça faisait beaucoup voilà et ensuite
et comme vous l'avez signalé donc la
suppression progressive des limitations
d'accès des femmes à certaines fonctions
quand je suis entré dans le commissariat
de l'air et si j'avais voulu entrer dans
le commissariat de la marine et bien la
porte était fermée elle a été fermée
jusqu'en 1993
voilà donc on est arrivé à l'égalité des
droits maintenant vous savez tous et
toutes que une égalité de droit ne
correspond pas toujours à inégalité
réelle et le ministère c'est attaché à
ce que ce soit concret dans les faits
que cette égalité voulue souhaitée
soit effectivement donc il y a plusieurs
mesures qui ont été prises tout d'abord
on a organisé le pilotage du domaine
puis après on s'est rendu compte qu'il
fallait des plans d'action un peu plus
un peu plus précis
donc d'abord le pour piloter cette
question de la mixité au sein du
ministère on a créé un poste donc mon
poste de haute fonctionnaire à l'égalité
des droits donc un haut fonctionnaire il
y en a dans tous les ministères je
suppose que vous savez de quoi il s'agit
mais pour peut-être pour ma camarade qui
doit pas savoir
c'est une personne qui est missionnée
par le ministre homophobe on a eu les
deux
qui doit s'assurer de la mise en oeuvre
du Plan d'action gouvernemental au sein
des armées donc en gros c'est l'agent de
liaison entre la vision gouvernementale
de la mixité et la façon dont on
l'intègre nous dans nos dans les
politiques et dans les textes qu'on
produit donc voilà je suis là depuis
septembre et je travaille avec l'équipe
de Madame Rome madame Isabelle Rome sur
les questions voilà d'égalité
professionnelle
voilà ensuite donc comme vous l'avez
mentionné il y a eu l'Observatoire de la
parité donc il a été créé en 2013 et en
fait il sert c'est une forme de
détecter les incohérences entre les
parcours des hommes les parcours des
femmes les analyser puis proposer des
solutions donc il se réunit une fois par
an donc le 8 mars on a choisi le 8 mars
Journée de la Femme la journée
international des droits des femmes et
c'est sous la la présidence la direction
du ministre le ministre est présent et
se fait présenter par toutes les armées
direction et services l'état
d'avancement de leurs travaux sur la
mixité donc vous voyez que c'est pris à
très très haut niveau dans notre voilà
dans notre dans notre ministère et enfin
parce que voilà même une femme
combattante ou une femme dans le
ministère des armées peut aussi être
confronté à des violences sexuelles
sexistes voilà ça n'épargne personne
donc peut-être que chez nous elles ont
tendance à réagir un peu plus
physiquement au genre de remarques on
peut avoir par ailleurs mais pas
toujours et donc on a des femmes qui
sont vraiment victimes de situations
déviantes et donc on a créé une cellule
qui s'appelle Thémis donc en 2014 et là
encore pour garantir parfaite
impartialité elle a été raccrochée
auprès du ministre elle est dirigée par
un contrôleur général des armées donc il
y a un petit peu à l'écart des autorités
pour que ce soit pas un système
hiérarchique pour permettre un peu la
libération de la parole donc ça a été
bien mis à l'écart et ça permet à tout
le monde homme et femme à partir du
moment où il est ressortissant des
armées donc il soit civil militaires ça
leur permet de signaler des actes des
viandes et après donc la cellule s'en
saisie fait des enquêtes diligences des
enquêtes et et traite éventuellement
porte l'affaire devant la justice
lorsque c'est nécessaire et si la
victime le souhaite donc il y a il y a
des femmes et des hommes donc chacun
peut saisir et ça a dépassé les
questions des violences sexuelles et des
discriminations sexuelles et depuis
l'année dernière c'est toutes sortes de
discriminations voilà là je lui handicap
la religion tout est tout est pris en
compte et c'est un voilà c'est un c'est
une c'est une cellule qui est très
regardée par nos alliés parce qu'ils
n'ont pas ça ils ont encore des justices
militaires ils ont encore un peu de mal
à traiter ces dossiers là donc on sert
d'aspiration dans nous auprès de nos
alliés
voilà donc qu'est-ce que ça produit tout
ça mais écoutez un vrai de vrai bon
résultat puisque puisqu'on vous l'a dit
on est devenu la quatrième armée la plus
féminisée du monde du monde et la
première au niveau européen donc voilà
on a certains satisfaits de tout ça mais
ensuite en suivant dans la durée les
résultats on s'est rendu compte que
on constaté une petite stagnation il y a
eu ce grand élan du début il y a eu
comme on l'a signalé
la suppression du du service militaire
et donc l'ouverture il y a eu donc un
vrai afflux de femmes mais cette afflux
tarissait et on voilà on se disait il se
passe quelque chose on a besoin de
savoir quoi
donc le ministère excusez-moi
donc le ministère a désigné une
directrice de projet donc c'était
l'amiral qui m'a précédé et elle a été
chargée de relancer cette dynamique
d'abord en allant écouter les gens sur
le terrain donc pendant 6 mois elle est
partie elle a écouté mais pourquoi
est-ce que les femmes qu'on engage s'en
vont pourquoi est-ce que elle ne
parviennent pas au grade supérieur etc
et sur cette base là il a établi
l'établi des plans donc elle a établi
d'abord le plan mixité
le plan mixité c'est une somme d'action
je crois qu'il y a à peu près 22 actions
en faveur de la mixité et qui est
orienté selon trois axes d'efforts c'est
le recrutement puisque si on veut
continuer à avoir des femmes et bien il
faut aller les chercher et c'est vrai
spontanément le ministère des armées pas
le lieu où une jeune fille
peut venir spontanément cela étant je
viens de la Légion d'honneur à
Saint-Denis et j'ai voilà et j'ai fait
Science Po et j'ai quand même eu envie
d'aller faire la guerrière et je fais
fais deux tours en Afghanistan donc vous
voyez le fixer des armées fait et peu
accueillir toutes sortes de profils et
donc ce plan mixité donc recrutement
d'abord ensuite la gestion c'est-à-dire
qu'on s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait
un moment de la carrière où les femmes
les femmes repartaient voilà elle se dit
bah j'ai fait 15 ans d'armée maintenant
j'ai des enfants je peux plus c'est trop
compliqué et donc on a travaillé la
gestion pour leur donner plus de
souplesse et leur permettre de rester et
après il y a toute une question
valorisation mais vous connaissez il
faut communiquer sur le fait qu'on peut
être femme au sein des armées c'est
aussi une des raisons pour lesquelles je
suis là engagez-vous
et voilà donc c'est c'était voilà c'est
un plan assez important après on a lancé
on s'est dit toute cette vision qu'on a
de la mixité il faut qu'elle diffuse au
sein de l'institution donc on a créé un
réseau c'est un peu plus d'un millier de
références on essaie d'avoir des binômes
c'est à la fois homme femme civil et
militaire et donc ils sont chargés à la
fois de diffuser cette vision de la de
la mixité mais aussi la loi puisque nul
n'est censé leurrer la loi mais surtout
on veut qu'ils aient un rôle de
médiateur parce que souvent le sexisme
ordinaire c'est pénible et quand ça
arrive chez tennis c'est-à-dire
potentiellement devant la justice c'est
l'échec de la formation de l'information
donc ils sont là voilà pour éteindre les
incendies avant que ça se propage trop
et il forme et ils informent les
commandants d'unités sur ces questions
là voilà ensuite on a eu un deuxième
plan parce qu'on s'est rendu compte
effectivement ce qui manquait c'est la
formation parce qu'on peut pas en
vouloir je pense à des hommes qui ont
passé ou des femmes parfois qui ont
passé 30 ans
dans un milieu qui est quand même assez
clos on peut pas trop le reprocher de
pas être très sensible aux évolutions
sociétales voilà donc on a des enfants
donc effectivement on se rend compte
qu'on est la génération Z c'est quelque
chose que voilà qu'on connaît pas trop
et donc il est très important qu'on
forme les gens à comment la société a
évolué donc on a fait un plan de
formation et donc l'objectif c'est que
chaque agent du ministère homme femme
civil militaire reçoivent au moins une
fois dans sa carrière et dans les quatre
ans on a fait un plan sur quatre ans une
formation sur cette sur cette question
là
voilà et nous avons je vais essayer de
d'accélérer et nous avons aussi fait un
pendant donc il rejoint un peu les
discussions de ce matin
une formation spécifique pour les
personnels militaires qui partent en
opération voilà parce que on se retrouve
dans des situations de guerre avec voilà
des tensions et ils peuvent aussi voir
sur le terrain des violences sexuelles
des choses comme ça donc on les forme on
les brief ils sont prêts à ils savent ce
qu'ils doivent faire et ils sont prêts à
intervenir ils sont prêt à agir voilà
selon les règles du droit international
que la Croix-Rouge a cité voilà donc
quels sont les résultats ben écoutez
très positifs puisque vous aviez posé
quelques questions donc je peux vous
dire que désormais on a un peu plus de
34 000 femmes militaires voilà donc un
taux de féminisation qui passait à 16 et
demi donc on progresse et j'espère qu'on
en restera pas là
dans le domaine des opérations on a
désormais donc plus de 9% donc en fait 9
et demi pour cent des militaires
déployés en opération sont des femmes
c'est à dire qu'en gros presque 1 sur 10
quand vous partez faire la guerre au
Mali 1 sur 10 sera une femme avec
l'intérêt que ça c'est qu'elle porte
cette vision de femme et se sera sans
doute plus sensible à des choses que un
homme verrait un petit peu moins et on a
parlé des problèmes des femmes des
enfants et les camps enfin toutes ces
choses-là qui sont les hommes sont
formés mais les femmes sont voilà elles
auront cette vision qui seraient qui
nous est extrêmement utile en termes de
concours désormais 20% des lauréats du
concours d'officier sont des femmes ce
qui veut dire que nous sommes en train
de faire un vivier qui sera à terme
puisqu'il faut 30 ans pour faire un
général qui sera à terme en position de
pouvoir et à l'École de guerre puisque
vous en parliez très nous savons dépassé
les objectifs du plan de ça va 13% des
réussites qui se lauréats qui sont des
femmes
voilà il y avait une question aussi
d'encadrement des écoles militaires on
s'est rendu compte en 2014 que les
beaucoup de problèmes de voilà
provenaient des écoles ou voilà ils
étaient jeunes ils étaient
exubérant ils avaient peut-être pas trop
de repères et donc on a mis des femmes
et Saint-Cyr a doublé le nombre de
cadres
féminin dans à l'école de Saint-Cyr
voilà donc vous avez maintenant
suffisamment de référents pas
suffisamment je sais pas si suffisant en
tout cas des référents féminins qui sont
là pour voilà rappeler les choses et
puis on a quelques belles réussites dans
l'armée de l'air nous avons le général
général de division aérien dominicarbiol
qui a dirigé l'école de l'air donc c'est
une grande première dans l'histoire de
l'armée de l'air qui est pas très
vieille 1935 mais quand même c'est une
grande première et nous avons depuis le
mois d'octobre l'ingénieur général de
l'armement Laura Chauvard qui dirige
l'école polytechnique donc vous voyez on
commence voilà on commence à vraiment
avoir du poids dans la structure et pour
l'accès aux responsabilités donc le haut
encadrement militaire compte aujourd'hui
presque alors pas 10% vous avez cité 10%
mais c'est presque nous sommes à 9,66%
voilà je fais un arrondi voilà je fais
un arrondi 10 % de fichiers généraux
voilà et là nous sommes les premiers
dans le monde voilà aucun pays n'a
autant de femmes aussi généraux donc je
suis assez fière de ça et nous avons ah
oui oui et ce qui est bien là depuis cet
été nous avons la première générale 5
étoiles je crois du monde aussi qui est
l'ingénieur général de classe
exceptionnelle Monique le grand Laroche
qui est Polytech et elle est inspectrice
générale des armées
donc voilà et cette politique bah
écoutez ça nous a valu d'être récompensé
par le label AFNOR alliance que vous
devez connaître et qui couvre les labels
égalité professionnelle et diversité
donc voilà ça c'est le point le point
pour le présent pour l'avenir bien
écoutez le ministère il reste très
engagé je serai à la manette je suis
relativement intéressée par le sujet
aussi et donc nous allons travailler à
promouvoir la continuer à promouvoir la
juste place des femmes dans les armées
quand je dis juste c'est à dire elle
doit toujours correspondre à leur
compétences à leur mérite et à leurs
ambitions il faut aussi prendre en
compte les souhaits des individus et
tout cela voilà ce qu'il ne faut pas
perdre de vue non plus c'est obligation
que nous avons vis-à-vis de la nation
qui est la finalité opérationnelle des
armées qui est d'assurer la protection
de la nation et cela reste avant tout
dogmatisme quel qu'il soit c'est notre
objectif unique voilà je vous remercie
merci beaucoup Madame la Commissaire
générale et je laisse maintenant la
parole au commandant clair officier de
de l'air et de l'espace pour son
intervention
merci monsieur le sénateur bonjour
madame la Présidente bonjour mesdames
messieurs voilà donc moi je vais vous
parler vraiment à mon niveau et sous le
prisme armé de l'Air et de l'Espace
puisque je suis officier de l'Armée de
l'Air et de l'Espace donc je vais vous
je vais aborder en fait mon parcours
vraiment de manière de manière simple
vous exposez aussi les motivations le
pourquoi en fait de mon engagement
initial qui commence à un peu à dater
maintenant et puis vous expliquer
actuellement ce que ce que je fais
donc je suis donc le commandant clair je
suis affectée sur la base aérienne 709
de Cognac cette base aérienne accueille
notamment l'école de l'aviation de
chasse donc tous les tous les pilotes de
chasse de l'armée de l'Air et de
l'Espace passent dans cette école et la
base aérienne 79 de Cognac accueille
également la 33e escadre de surveillance
de reconnaissance et d'attaque j'insiste
sur cette unité puisque c'est l'unité
dont je fais partie aujourd'hui depuis
maintenant trois ans
donc je suis aviatrice et très fière de
l'être je suis officier renseignement
actuellement chef du bureau à puits
renseignement aux opérations donc de la
33e escadre de surveillance de
reconnaissance et d'attaque qui est si
vous ne le savez pas une unité de combat
qui met en oeuvre les systèmes de drone
Reaper ce sont des drones moyennes
altitude longue endurance de l'Armée de
l'Air et de l'Espace qui sont mis en
oeuvre en opération entre autres sur la
base aérienne projetée de Niamey au
Niger actuellement
donc j'ai participé à différentes
opérations extérieures depuis mon
engagement qui date de 2005 maintenant
donc plusieurs opérations extérieures
sur des théâtres d'opérations très
différents et pour des missions très
différentes également et à ce jour au
sein de la 33e escadre de surveillance
de reconnaissance et d'attaque j'ai
réalisé déjà donc deux opérations
extérieures et je m'apprête à partir en
janvier pour la troisième
au sein donc de la 33e escape de
surveillance de reconnaissance et
d'attaque je suis en fait directement
intégré et membre d'équipage
l'équipage des systèmes Reaper nous
sommes quatre personnels un pilote à
distance un opérateur capteur un
coordinateur tactique donc là c'est mon
c'est mon poste et un opérateur image
pour vous imaginez ou illustrer un peu
plus mon rôle en fait au sein de
l'équipage je dirais que je suis comme
un chef d'orchestre en lien avec les
structures de commandement et de
contrôle et l'équipage pour atteindre
l'effet militaire en fait qui nous est
donné pendant pendant nos missions si je
peux on a des écrans des écrans partout
et voilà on cherche à gérer au mieux au
mieux la mission
donc nous participons également à
différents événements sur le théâtre le
territoire national également tels que
les dpsa donc les dispositifs
particuliers de sûreté aériennes que
vous pouvez trouver par exemple lors des
14 juillet il y a une fin du 14 juillet
qui a lieu tous les ans une bulle de
protection en fait qui est mise ou sur
des grands sommets ce genre de choses
nous sommes également à contribution et
nous participons également à des
exercices majeurs de type wolfa qui sont
utilisés en fait à l'entraînement des
unités de l'Armée de l'Air et de
l'Espace au conflit de haute intensité
notamment
donc comme vous pouvez le voir l'Armée
de l'Air et de l'Espace et engager en
permanence tant sur le territoire
national qu'en opération extérieure et
encore plus mon unité et je suis très
fière de participer à toutes ces
missions je dirais 24 heures sur 24 donc
je vais vous décrire maintenant
mon parcours en fait le parcours vous
allez pouvoir le voir de de d'une femme
qui a pu progresser en fait au sein de
l'institution et plus particulièrement
de l'Armée de l'Air et de l'Espace je me
suis engagée donc en 2005 en tant que
sous-officier avec le grade de sergent
dans le domaine toujours du
renseignement
ce qui m'a permis de voir effectivement
que l'Armée de l'Air et de l'Espace
était l'armée quand même la plus
féminisée aujourd'hui on arrive avec un
taux de 25% au sein des différents parmi
les différentes armées en France donc là
j'ai eu la scolarité à l'école des
sous-officiers donc qui se trouve sur la
base de Rochefort la base aérienne de
Rochefort ou là j'ai pu me confronter à
mes premières expériences en tant que
que militaire
ensuite j'ai
pu par par voie interne donc au bout de
quelques années avec une envie une
motivation de progresser et de et de
réussir ce que moi je rappelle la danse
ça va être vraiment le le coeur en fait
de mon de mon récit c'est qu'en fait
tant qu'on est motivé qu'on a envie de
réussir et qu'on a envie de servir de
servir la France on a toute notre place
en tant que femme tout comme un homme
dans la dans l'Armée de l'Air et de
l'Espace donc j'ai j'ai ensuite
bénéficié de l'escalier social en
réussissant le concours interne pour
devenir officier
l'armée de l'arrière et de l'espace
offre cette chance en fait de pouvoir
commencer je dis entre guillemets tout
petit c'est pas péjor mais pouvoir
rentrer par la petite porte et pouvoir
s'élever par la suite si on en a
l'ambition et et l'envie et puis
aujourd'hui et ben me voilà officier
supérieur
j'ai également pu lorsque j'ai été donc
à l'école militaire de l'air qui
n'existe plus aujourd'hui puisque
maintenant nous avons l'école de de
l'Air et de l'Espace on peut toujours
entrer par parois de concours j'ai pu
également passer une année d'échange
donc à firstonefelbruck donc à l'école
de l'air allemande et là ça a été une
expérience aussi très enrichissante pour
pouvoir faire des comparaisons entre le
système français le système allemand et
également la place de la femme dans dans
les armées alors pourquoi j'ai voulu
j'ai voulu m'engager
en tant que militaire moi j'avais envie
en fait à l'issue de mes études j'ai
quand même fait donc un universitaire
donc une licence en langue étrangère
appliquée j'avais envie en fait de
d'autres choses j'avais envie de d'être
comment dire membre à part entière de
dans quelque chose pour moi qui était
très important c'était servir servir mon
pays adhérer à une cause qui me tenait à
cœur être force de conviction et j'avais
vraiment envie de faire un métier que je
savais que je ne pouvais faire qu'en
étant militaire donc c'est vraiment moi
ce qui a guidé mon ce qui a guidé mon
parcours et j'avais envie aussi
d'adhérer aux valeurs militaires qui
sont pour moi le respect l'exemplarité
la loyauté l'abnégation est toujours la
volonté de servir la France mais pour le
coup par le métier des armes
j'ai servi dans différentes unités qui
m'ont permis de me confronter à
l'exercice des responsabilités toujours
au niveau qui m'était donné donc tant en
opération que sur le territoire national
dans des contextes parfois très très
différents et c'est cette variété de
situation qui rend en fait l'exercice du
du commandement très très enrichissant à
mon sens et je rappelle toujours à mon
niveau donc se remettre en question
faire preuve de courage de loyauté être
juste aussi c'est pour moi c'est très
très important et ce sont autant de
qualités qui pour moi enfin c'est très
important que que tous les chefs et ses
qualités en fait qui sont pour moi très
très importantes et ça que l'on soit un
homme ou une femme
se le débat aujourd'hui est très
intéressant puisqu'en fait on voit que
le ministère des armées a
à mis pas mal de choses en avant en fait
pour que l'on puisse trouver notre place
et pouvoir évoluer au même titre que les
hommes et que nos compétences en fait
soient
autant valorisés au même titre que les
compétences des hommes
pour ma part le fait d'être une femme
dans l'armée de l'espace c'est pas un
obstacle tant qu'on est motivé qu'on a
envie qu'on a cette cette volonté il
faut avoir effectivement du du caractère
également mais pour moi les contraintes
et les chances de progresser restent les
mêmes que pour un homme ce qui est plus
délicat à mon sens mais je pense autant
pour un homme que pour une femme ça
reste en fait de trouver l'équilibre
entre engagement opérationnel et vie
familiale comme vous avez pu voir quand
je vous ai décrit un peu le le mon
travail au quotidien dans mon unité
c'est en fait trouver
on est engagé partout tout le temps en
permanence puis ben on a quand on quand
on quand on est jeune on est on est
plein d'ambition on a envie de faire
plein de choses de voyager partout et en
fait après quand on commence à avoir une
famille là se pose se pose d'autres
questions et c'est ça en fait le point
sur lequel je c'est trouver l'équilibre
entre réussite professionnelle et vie
familiale accomplie
voilà pour moi
voilà le temps est passé merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup comme mon don pour votre
témoignage je me tourne maintenant vers
anakvite qui intervient en
visioconférence depuis l'Ukraine et en
anglais j'invite les participants à se
munir de ce petit outil qui vous a été
remis pour permettre d'avoir
notre discussion avec notre
interlocuteur
bonjour à tous bonjour J'espère que vous
pouvez m'entendre oui on vous entend
ez allez
nous vivons une époque très compliquée
c'est un honneur pour moi de pouvoir
prendre la parole d'ici aujourd'hui et
vous parler des forces armées en Ukraine
et de la part des femmes et de la
réponse à
l'agression russe je parlais du projet
de plaidoyer qui s'appelle bataillon
invisible qui vise à défendre des femmes
et les droits des femmes moi j'en fais
partie juste un honneur pour moi ce
projet a commencé dans le cadre d'un
travaux de recherche sociologique en
a commencé en 2013 avec l'occupation de
la Crimée et pendant 9 ans les femmes
ont participé de façon très active dans
la réponse à l'agression russe y compris
sur le champ de bataille
et
[Musique]
je l'ai réglementations ont évolué
pendant cette période de temps de façon
assez significative
on a on parle des femmes dans les forces
armées mais c'est toujours très utile
selon moi de vous donner quelques
chiffres
ici vous pouvez donc voir les évolutions
depuis 2013
malheureusement nous n'avons pas les
chiffres exacts pour ce qui est de la
présence des femmes dans les forces
armées à l'heure actuelle vous voyez
donc que leur nombre a augmenté ces
dernières années
vous avez donc le nombre de femmes y
compris les civils
et à droite
du tableau
vous avez le pourcentage
de femmes
qui sont engagés dans l'armée dans les
forces armées en Ukraine nous n'avons
pas les chiffres exacts pour la
situation actuelle
les représentants du ministère de la
Défense au cours de l'été en tant que la
vis ministre
déclaré qu'il y avait environ 50 000
femmes engagées dans les forces
également l'Ukraine
5% de ces femmes sont sur la ligne de
front elles se battent
ça c'était déjà il y a quelques mois et
il est tout à fait possible que les
chiffres
soient plus élevés aujourd'hui
donc à ce jour il n'y a qu'une femme
générale
[Musique]
donc
en 2013 on ne
sait pas grand chose des femmes qui se
battaient pas beaucoup de chiffres
vous ne connaissait pas vraiment les
conditions également de leur
participation et on a commencé à
s'intéresser à la question et c'est ce
qui a déclenché cette étude du
s'agissait de voir quel était la
participation des femmes dans les
opérations militaires anti-terroriste
dans l'est de l'Ukraine et identifier
les réussites et les défis
liés à l'intégration de ces femmes dans
le secteur de la défense donc c'était
une un travail essentiellement
sociologique
mener au moyen d'entretien semi
structuré très approfondi
experts et
on a également vu qu'elle était
la représentation donc de ces femmes
dans l'armée auprès des médias donc
qu'est-ce qu'on a vu au cours de ces
travaux de recherche et bien les
entretiens avec les femmes
qui se battaient sur la ligne de front
on fournit les renseignements suivants
nous avons constaté que les femmes
étaient confrontés à une certaine
discrimination à ce stade on les inciter
à ne pas s'engager de l'armée souvent on
leur proposait un refus du fait de
différence stéréotypes genre
elles étaient perçues
comme n'étant pas
suffisamment forte pour pouvoir se
battre un prix de faire autre chose
donc certaines femmes
déjà dans l'armée était confrontée à
certains stéréotypes liées aux gens
notre structure
n'était pas à la hauteur non plus donc
que ce soit l'uniforme les différents
équipements
les services de santé
et il y avait également des
écarts en fait entre les devoirs
[Musique]
officiels annoncé et réalisé et donc
trouver
constater que
certaines femmes qui menaient des
opérations actives finalement été
référencés comme étant comptable
occupant d'autres postes dans des
bureaux
et
les droits des femmes
dans le secteur finalement
n'était pas totalement respecté
donc
et donc comme je vous le disais
c'était difficile d'avoir un bon aperçu
de la participation des femmes dans les
forces armées en Ukraine
alors
le ministère de
la Santé
interdisait aux femmes d'occuper 150
postes différents
elle ne pouvait pas avoir accès au poste
de combat par exemple
et
ce règlement avait également des
répercussions sur d'autres
aspects de la vie des femmes il y avait
et également des réglementations sur
les hommes et les femmes dans les
transports aussi
que nous avions à l'époque entraîner une
discrimination horizontale et verticale
des femmes
dans le marché du travail par exemple
certaines professions qui leur étaient
interdites ça c'est discriminations
horizontale
l'armée est bien il y avait certaines
carrières qui leur étaient interdites
également elle pouvait par exemple
travailler en cuisine être simple
cuisinière mais ne pouvait pas être chef
cuisinier dans la cuisine par exemple
donc
certains postes donc comme je vous le
disais leur était interdit
les femmes d'avoir accès aux avantages
sociaux associés à ces postes et au
salaire également
donc
résultat de notre première étude baillon
bataillon invisible
nous nous sommes branchés donc sur les
droits des femmes dans l'armée afin de
d'avoir des arguments pour des campagnes
de plaidoyer
cette enquête a également fourni des
données empiriques
cela a donc a permis de donner des
arguments aux militantes et cela a
également été un appel au changement
notification des normes formées et un
formats à la fin de protéger les droits
des femmes dans le secteur de la défense
donc cette étude c'était la première
étape de ce projet bataillon invisible
qui est encore en cours
nous sommes trois chercheurs donc nous
le penchons sur la vie des femmes dans
le secteur militaire
[Musique]
à la vie civile et nous sommes également
penchés sur le harcèlement sexuel dans
l'armée deux films documentaires
également qui sont disponibles en ligne
qui parle des femmes dans l'armée en
Ukraine il y a des femmes qui font la
guerre en Ukraine
et nous avons un club des
deux
l'équipe est composé de plus de 20
personnes nous avons également une
campagne de communication mais en fait
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui
sont joints à nous au fil des ans alors
quelles sont les résultats de ce projet
alors bah du projet en tant que tel
directement mais qu'est-ce qui a changé
depuis 2015
je dois dire que
la question des droits
des femmes étaient quelque chose qui
intéressait les
organisations de la société civile
et d'autres
représentants officiels alors il y a eu
beaucoup de synergies de coopération
entre les différents acteurs et cela a
permis de changer les politiques
et à ce jour
je peux dire que en Ukraine plus aucune
profession n'est interdite aux femmes
les postes de combat ont été ouverts aux
femmes
la formation militaire est maintenant
disponible également pour les femmes
donc nous devrions voir plus d'une femme
générale d'ici quelques années j'espère
nous voyons également que l'accès
de s'améliore pour les femmes
on constate également que
l'infrastructure se développe afin de
permettre une meilleure égalité entre
les hommes et les femmes donc les choses
sont pas encore parfaite mais elles
avancent
et on retrouve ses objectifs d'égalité
homme-femme dans les programmes de
développement
nationaux et sectorielle par exemple
un plan d'action
[Musique]
pour ce qui est de la protection des
femmes dans l'armée c'est un plan
d'action qui va jusqu'à 2025 si
l'interprète entend bien l'intervenantes
parce que le son est très très mauvais
et les femmes deviennent vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup plus visible dans les
forces armées en Ukraine
donc par rapport
je dois dire que les femmes jouissent
beaucoup plus de droits dans le secteur
de la défense
et leur contribution est bien mieux
reconnue
mais bien entendu il y a encore toujours
une marge d'amélioration possible
certains défis quelques difficultés que
j'aimerais mentionner ça en quoi
donc ça ça reste toujours une difficulté
je pense que c'est le cas dans beaucoup
d'armées dans le monde donc ça reste
un des points d'amélioration il faut
aussi améliorer l'infrastructure à
l'intention des femmes dans l'armée mais
là aussi les choses évoluent
les infrastructures qui soient plus
inclusives
[Musique]
alors là une marge de manoeuvre
néanmoins et aussi le leadership des
femmes dans le secteur
dans les forces armées me disent souvent
qu'elle manque un petit peu de
perspective d'évolution de carrière
donc au cours des 9 dernières années les
forces armées en Ukraine ont connu une
forte transformation je pense que vous
le savez certainement mais il y a aussi
donc des évolutions positives en termes
d'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
je vous remercie de votre attention vous
avez ici le lien vers notre site web une
visible bataillon bataillon invisible
et vous pourrez y trouver donc tous les
documents dont je vous ai parlé vous
avez des questions je serais ravie d'y
répondre
merci beaucoup merci Madame et
maintenant je souhaiterais qu'on puisse
donner la parole
à notre ambassadeur en Ukraine monsieur
Étienne de Poncin
allô
merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur un très
grand honneur pour nous de vous donner
la parole à la fin de cette troisième
table ronde vous êtes en direct de Kiev
et avant de vous laisser la parole tout
de suite on voudrait vous adresser nos
félicitations puisque vous avez été
promu ce matin officiel international du
mérite
un grand merci à vous et effectivement
je suis à Kiev où nous avons subi comme
vous le savez hier une nouvelle frappe
sur les infrastructures énergétiques et
critiques qui cette fois peut-être plus
que les autres fois d'ailleurs été assez
douloureuse pour eux pour les ukrainiens
et notamment pour pour la capitale qui
est qui a été plongée assez largement
dans le noir et l'eau est en train de
revenir l'électricité aussi mais enfin
voilà traverse une phase et les
Ukrainiens surtout d'ailleurs traversent
une phase une phase compliquée merci à
vous pour votre pour votre soutien et
pour votre votre appui
celles sont des femmes puisque c'est le
thème dans les dans les conflits armés
je crois que l'oratrice précédente a
très bien décrit
la très grande implication en fait des
femmes dans dans l'armée ukrainienne
avec
des responsabilités c'est une armée qui
est assez largement féminisée même si
évidemment on n'est pas à parité et ceci
reflète en fait une des caractéristiques
de la lutte contre la guerre d'agression
russe qui est le fait que c'est pas
simplement une armée qui se bat contre
une armée mais c'est une nation la
nation ukrainienne qui se défend contre
contre l'agression russe
et donc la place la place des femmes est
importante sur le front elle est aussi
importante dans les bataillons
territoriaux qui sont en fait envoyés
par les par les villes par les mers pour
aller sur sur le front donc il y a
vraiment une vraie
une vraie
prise en charge
de l'ensemble de la population
s'agissant des défenses militaires et
pas seulement des hommes mais les femmes
sont aussi peut-être encore plus que les
hommes aussi les hommes militaires elles
sont les très grandes victimes de ce
conflit d'agression il faut bien en
avoir conscience
elles ont subi si on commence par là
d'abord en fait de l'exil puisque très
grand nombre de crinienne avec leurs
enfants ou du quitter le territoire
ukrainien c'est 5 millions puisque comme
vous savez les hommes de porter les
arbres c'est-à-dire du 18 à 60 ans ne
sont pas autorisés à accepter doivent
rester sur le territoire donc ce sont
les réfugiés sont très majoritairement
des femmes avec avec les enfants et donc
elles ont dû subir à la fois la
séparation familiale et puis aussi
évidemment cette exil à l'extérieur ce
statut de réfugiés s'agissant de la
France puisque nous sommes en France
nous en avons accueilli 100 000 100000
réfugiés Ukrainiens donc 18000 enfants
et l'accueil a été très très très
positif et très très chaleureux et
jamais entendu aucune
plainte ou critiques de la part des
autorités ukrainiennes sur l'accueil qui
a été
accorder aux réfugiés
ukrainien et donc qui sont en fait assez
largement majoritaires des femmes
ukrainiennes avec avec leur famille ça
c'est elles sont aussi évidemment mais
c'est
très sûrs
à l'extérieur du pays de réfugiés et
environ aussi 5 millions de déplacés à
terme c'est-à-dire des populations qui
malheureusement ont dû fuir leur
lieu d'habitation habituelle pour se
réfugier généralement à l'ouest du pays
mais évidemment là où c'est le plus
dramatique c'est les
crimes qu'elle subissent que ce soit
essentiellement les viols et les crimes
d'agression sexuelle qu'elle que les
femmes ukrainiennes subissent lorsque le
parti du territoire ukrainien et soumis
à l'occupation russe et malheureusement
on le voit au fur et à mesure
de la libération de ces territoires ça
d'abord été
bout de chat puis Isio mais maintenant
Kerson on voit bien que que ces crimes
sexuels sont très largement
représentées et que ce sont évidemment
les femmes qui les subissent en premier
mais comme il y a beaucoup de crimes
d'autres natures aussi c'est un peu
notre responsabilité nous
occidentaux et nous censés en
particulier d'attirer l'attention des
Ukrainiens et notamment du procureur
général sur le caractère tout à fait
inacceptable de ses crimes sexuels à
des femmes et donc c'est un dialogue que
nous avons très très régulièrement avec
avec lui avec le procureur costume nous
avions avec sa prédécesserie
pour un peu le sensibiliser parce qu'il
y a tellement en fait
d'enquête qui sont ouvertes on parle de
cinq crimes de guerre cette fois-ci on
parle à peu près de 50
000 enfin plusieurs dizaines de milliers
c'est pour vous donner un peu la
profondeur sur cambrides d'expression
des crimes russes dans les territoires
occupés et encore une grande partie du
territoire qui était libérée donc on est
déjà sur des chiffres qui sont assez
considérables et donc c'est un peu à
nous aussi d'insister auprès des
Ukrainiens pour que les crimes sexuels
fassent bien partie de ce recensement ce
qui est le cas évidemment
mais peut-être pas
au niveau exact peut-être qu'ils sont
sous représentés enfin les crimes
sexuels sont peut-être sous représentés
dans le recensement des crimes de guerre
c'est sans doute un peu mon sentiment
ceci dit des efforts
Ukrainiens sont faits et par exemple le
procureur général que précédemment a
ouvert au sein de sa procuration
générale d'une très grosse une très
grosse machine en crème les systèmes de
l'ancien bloc soviétique et donc il a
ouvert un département spécifique dédié
aux crimes sexuels
et donc avec une équipe de procureurs et
qu'il n'apporte maintenant de former
nous avons proposé d'ailleurs la trade
en la matière nous avons proposé aussi
de l'équipement et donc nous travaillons
sur cette base là il y a une prise de
conscience je dirais qui existait déjà
mais que nous renforçons encore sur le
caractère absolument
étendu et complètement inacceptable
abominable de ces crimes là du côté
peut-être pour pas être long du côté
français donc nous avons aussi insisté
sur le volet
femme et donc je suis heureux de vous
annoncer que parmi l'aide humanitaire
que nous déployons en faveur de
l'Ukraine qui est très conséquent comme
vous le savez nous avons un certain
nombre de programmes alors je vais
parler de ceux qui sont gérés par Paris
qui sont spécifiquement dans des centrés
sur ces problématiques là alors ce sont
souvent des problèmes des programmes
régionaux aussi accueillir et aider les
fameux crâniennes en dehors de
frontières comme je l'évoquais
précédemment donc nous avons environ
pour 4,3 millions de programmes donc
géré par le Centre de Crise Quai d'Orsay
et où les citer donc
nous avons un projet qui s'appelle
l'action santé femme et qui fournit des
soins en gynécologie obstétrique aux
femmes ukrainiennes qui sont réfugiés en
Roumanie et sur la frontière entre
l'Ukraine et la Roumanie nous avons
aussi
terre des hommes qui a fait un programme
pour aider à la protection sanitaire et
psychologique des enfants et des maires
dans les centres d'accueil et de transit
c'était un projet qui pourrait nous
crâne la mode de vie en Hongrie la
Roumanie pour environ et puis nous avons
aussi aidé l'ONG globale Survivor fund
qui travaillait aussi avec les
survivants à des violences sexuelles
liées au conflit en Ukraine donc ça
c'est pour la partie géré depuis Paris
depuis 100 de crise et puis l'ambassade
avec ses moyens évidemment du modeste à
appuyer une ONG ukrainienne après donc
des besoins qui
donnent accueil à des femmes qui ont été
victimes de violences sexuelles il y a
un foyer
à Kiev
il y en a trois collier un foyer à Kiev
un foyer
de la Hongrie et s'agissant du foyer de
Kiev madame Braun pivel à la présidente
de l'Assemblée nationale lorsqu'elle
s'est rendue à Kiev il y a quelques
semaines avec sa délégation elle a tenu
à visiter ce foyer et rencontrer les
mères et les enfants donc c'est des
foyers d'étapes qui qui permettent
aux femmes et à leurs enfants de se
reconstituer
de reprendre des forces après à des
violences qui peuvent être de diverses
natures ça peut être lié à la guerre ça
peut aussi être des violences conjugales
il y a plusieurs hypothèses mais donc
que nous nous aidons ces foyers là voilà
pour ce qui est de Kiev et s'il y a des
questions je serai très heureux d'y
répondre
merci infiniment Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
pour
vous explications très intéressantes et
je rends la parole à madame la
Présidente je crois que
une question
alors très rapidement
d'abord merci évidemment à tous les
intervenants dans dans cette partie
comme d'ailleurs dans les précédentes
quand même on a parlé à plusieurs
reprises de l'application de la
résolution 13.25 et je me souviens que
moi-même j'étais intervenu il y a
quelques années pour l'application de
cette de cette résolution concernant
notamment ce qui se passait au niveau de
la Palestine et j'avais écrit au
secrétaire général de l'ONU et du coup
quand même je me dis que peut-être on
pourrait avoir une une c'était en 2015
je regardais la date de mon intervention
c'est pas hier et du coup je me disais
quand même face à tout ce qu'on a dit et
qui s'applique qui pourrait normalement
peut protéger aider à la protection
notamment des femmes dans les conflits
je me demandais si on pouvait pas avoir
une initiative au Sénat que ce soit au
niveau de la délégation au droit des
femmes ou encore plus plus globalement
parce que cette on voit bien que cette
résolution 13-25 n'est pas appliquée et
je n'ai pas enfin l'illusion de dire
parce qu'on va intervenir au niveau du
Sénat ça va ça va fonctionner loin sans
faut mais je me dis que ça peut être une
petite pierre qui peut quand même
relancer les choses donc ça c'est ma
première remarque et suggestions et la
deuxième c'est que dans cette table
ronde spécifiquement et notamment par
avec la participation
des des femmes militaires on va dire je
sais pas comment on dit
désormais
il y a eu bien on a bien assisté sur le
côté actrice dans dans les conflits et
pas seulement victimes et je pense de de
fait à nos amis Kurdes et comme on a une
représentante là qui est là qui est
intervenue tout à l'heure peut-être
aussi elle peut nous donner faire
bénéficier de de de de l'expérience
des femmes kurdes combattantes et on a
vu combien elles étaient courageuses
face à adaesh elle continue à l'être
voilà donc de remarques suggestions
questions je sais pas comment dire merci
beaucoup
donc Joël guerrier mais puis après je
pense qu'il y a pas d'autres
interventions pour clôturer je sais pas
voilà à vous faire collègues moi je
voudrais revenir sur la situation en
Ukraine et je voudrais surtout profiter
de cette occasion pour féliciter
remercier notre ambassadeur parce que je
crois que vraiment il a fait un travail
considérable avec beaucoup de courage il
nous a rendu très fiers de notre pays
merci aussi aux gendarmes qui sont allés
sur place et j'avais peut-être une
question ou une demande plutôt puisqu'en
fait je lui ai fait l'usuion en début de
cette table ronde la prix Nobel de la
paix au Alexandra mavicsouk nous m'avait
dit qu'en fait ces gendarmes faisaient
un travail extraordinaire mais qui
n'était peut-être pas suffisamment
longtemps la rotation était trop rapide
j'ai essayé de faire remonter peut-être
que vous pourriez nous aider Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur aussi à faire remonter
cette information je sais qu'il est
difficile de vivre longtemps bon plus de
trois mois apparemment ces missions de
gendarmerie mais pour mettre justement
les femmes en confiance pour essayer de
recueillir plus facilement les
informations auprès des enquêteurs et
puis peut-être une petite question nous
avions aussi rencontrer des femmes des
ukrainiennes qui étaient venus en France
plaider la cause pour leur mari leur
mari qui était emprisonnés en Russie
dont elle n'avait pas de nouvelles
c'était il y a quelques semaines est-ce
que vous avez des informations à ce
sujet Monsieur l'Ambassadeur merci
beaucoup chers collègues alors comme
vous avez été interpellé madame si vous
voulez intervenir rapidement bien
entendu vous êtes on vous écoute
merci beaucoup de m'avoir donné cette
possibilité
juste je viens sur le ceux qui disent
les madame commandante sur la question
des femmes dans l'armée
exactement d'accord avec les dents moi
personnellement je travaille sur la
question des femmes cultes et pour ma
thèse par contre je travaille sur la
question des femmes combattantes au cœur
des stands et exactement ce que pour les
femmes c'est très important parfois
quand on parle sur les hommes on parle
sur Valence sur la loutre et le objectif
mais pour les femmes il y a deux ennemis
en même temps sur la question de loot et
en même temps sur la question de
comment dire le rapport sociaux de sexe
pour les femmes et exactement c'est ça
c'est pourquoi le parcours des femmes
c'est très très difficile en même temps
il doit combattre contre les ennemis et
d'autres côtés il doit combattre contre
le patriarcat qu'on ne le trouve partout
ici partout bien sûr le degré c'est pas
la même chose mais exactement c'est
partout et c'est une question
universelle c'est pour ça je fais le
cidre le courage de ces femmes qui qui
ont combattent le cliché pour combattre
pour renforcer la statue des femmes dans
les milieux qu'on le considère plutôt
très masculin pas pour les femmes plutôt
mais voilà c'est une courage et je le
fais félicite merci bien merci beaucoup
madame pour votre témoignage qui
alimente aussi le débat et les débats
qu'on avait que nous avons eu ce matin
je voudrais à l'issue de cette pardon
excuse-moi chers collègues je voulais à
l'issue de ces trois tables rondes déjà
remercier nos intervenantes et
intervenants qui ont permis d'éclairer
ces débats qui nous ont ouvert aussi des
possibilités d'action puisque ça a été
repris par Laurence Cohen Laurence
Rossignol et d'autres intervenants Max
Brisson Martin Loïc Hervé donc
véritablement l'idée ce matin c'était
d'avoir un temps fort sur les droits des
femmes parce que demain c'est la journée
internationale de l'élimination des
violences faites aux femmes mais ça a
été dit dans nos débats oui à partir du
moment où il y a des violences il y en a
aussi elles sont exacerbées dans les
territoires en guerre dans les
territoires qui sont
je ne concluent pas on me dit que
l'ambassadeur souhaitait parler pardon
excusez-moi donc si vous pouvez faire
assez rapidement monsieur
[Musique]
merci beaucoup ma présidente c'était
pour réagir rapidement sur sur la
mission
de des gendarmes légistes qui étaient
donc c'est on est plusieurs missions
effectivement de gendarmes légistes de
lire CGN qui sont donc nos gendarmes
légismes alors ils ne travaillaient pas
spécifiquement c'est pour ça que vous
avez pas mentionné un moment mon
intervention luminaire sur les crimes
sexuels c'était il travaillait sur les
fosses communes ou sur les morts mais
pas sur les crimes sexuels en tant que
tel que nous avons proposé c'est une
aide à la formation comme je l'évoquais
aussi une aide de matériel voir
recueillir des preuves par exemple en
cas de crime sexuel mais ces gendarmes
qui en fait l'émission ont été très très
ont été conduites en étroite de
concertation avec le avec le procureur
donc justement sur certains lieux comme
izum elles ont été prolongées d'une
semaine qu'un jour en fonction de la
demande et en fait lorsque la mission
s'est achevée ils sont ils sont repartis
et maintenant nous sommes en train de
regarder pour faire une nouvelle mission
malheureusement comme je l'ai dit les
crimes à chaque fois réapparaissent qui
seraient cette fois sur Carson mais qui
se situerait dans le cadre de la de la
Cour pénale internationale de la CPI
c'est encore nous en sommes encore
vraiment à l'analyse complètement
préliminaire pour cette possible
nouvelle mission de je voulais apporter
et bien vous savez eu raison on vous
remercie Monsieur l'Ambassadeur et
vraiment merci pour ce temps consacré à
la délégation droit des femmes donc
j'étais en train de conclure et
désormais je ne me laisse plus couper je
vais conclure puisqu'on avait imaginé
plutôt une fin vers midi on a d'autres
tous et toutes d'autres engagements donc
cette matinée elle avait été imaginée
par la délégation au droit des femmes
parce que demain c'est la journée
internationale de l'élimination des
violences faites aux femmes nous avions
pensé avec la délégation collectivement
que c'était intéressant de s'intéresser
à ces ces territoires en guerre parce
que lorsqu'il y a des violences faites
aux femmes elles sont exacer et ça a été
dit dans ces territoires alors oui
l'égalité c'est un combat de tous les
jours c'est un combat dans les
territoires où les démocraties sont en
place parce que l'égalité elle n'est pas
n'existe pas pour le moment un certain
nombre de travaux du Parlement notamment
tente d'améliorer cette égalité je
regarde la rapporteur Martin filleul qui
porte actuellement une proposition de
loi avec sa collègue et moi-même donc
Dominique Verrien sur l'égalité dans la
fonction publique monter en puissance si
on veut faire un petit résumé parce que
oui l'égalité passe aussi par l'égalité
économique et professionnelle et
l'autonomisation des femmes donc ce que
je voudrais vous dire c'est qu'on a
entendu aussi ce matin des témoignages
difficiles à entendre parce que les
violences faites aux femmes lorsqu'on
dit ça on ne les décrit pas on ne les
nomme pas précisément elles ont été
nommées et décrites précisément ce matin
grâce à vous docteur aussi lorsque vous
avez parlé de la réparation mais grâce
aux témoignages de la journaliste aussi
et à partir du moment où réussi à nommer
à regarder à dénoncer à s'indigner on
fait juste le début du chemin en réalité
parce que les slogans femmes vie liberté
on est tous on trouve ça porteur femme
sécurité mais au-delà des slogans et
bien nous avons besoin d'action nous
avons besoin de se doter des moyens à la
fois pour les organisations humanitaires
mais à la fois évidemment pour le cadre
juridique à l'international pour pouvoir
combattre ces exactions et ses violences
faites aux femmes dans les territoires
en guerre donc merci à vous également
d'avoir donné un éclairage sur les
armées parce que la place des femmes
dans l'armée c'est aussi symptomatique
et c'est aussi très éclairant sur
société et et la
représentation de l'égalité plus il y
aura de femmes dans l'armée dans les
armées plus l'égalité progressera c'est
pareil dans toutes les sphères comme
c'est pareil dans le milieu
professionnel c'est pareil en politique
donc bravo à vous mesdames d'avoir
représenté les armées ce matin notamment
donc je ne vais pas être plus long ce
que je vais vous dire c'est vraiment
merci d'avoir participé à ce temps à la
veille de cette journée internationale
et un espace public en France qui est
plus égalitaire c'est un espace public
plus sûr donc tout le monde y gagne les
hommes et les femmes belle journée à
tous et merci aux trois animateurs des
tables rondes qui ont fait un très bon
travail Merci à VOUS bonne journée